19h45 sur la Chaîne
Parlementaire bonjour à tous et
bienvenue sur Public Sénat hier les
sénateurs ont repris l'examen du projet
de loi Hôpital patients santé et
territoire bousculant l'ordre du jour de
cette semaine normalement réservé à
l'initiative parlementaire les sénateurs
ont obtenu hier l'assurance de la part
de la ministre de la Santé Roseline
Bachelot que le diplôme de sag-femme
serait reconnu d'ici 2010 au niveau de
Master début mai il faut rappeler que
des milliers d'étudiants et de
sag-femmes avaient défilé à Paris pour
demander l'intégration de leur cursus à
celui de l'université c'est donc cette
partie de l'examen du projet de loi que
je vous propose de revoir ce matin bonne
séance à
tous cet article nouvellement créé à à
l'issue des travaux de la commission des
affaires sociales aborde spécifiquement
la question de la formation des
sagesfemmes et de la la reconnaissance
de leur diplôme madame la ministre vous
le savez les sages-femmes militent
depuis de nombreuses années pour que
leur profession soit reconnue à sa juste
valeur à l'heure où leur mission leurs
compétences et leurs responsabilités ne
cessent d'augmenter il est indéniable
que les sages-femmes jouent un rôle
décisif dans les services de gynéc
obstétrique cette spécialité forte
d'environ 20000 professionnels médicals
qui a la compétence pour pratiquer seul
le suivi médical de la grossesse normale
que nous connaissons fort bien les
sagesfemmes sont également compétente
pour pour dépister les situations à
risque et en cas de grossesse
pathologique peuvent pratiquer des actes
sur prescription du médecin
elles attendent donc une reconnaissance
juste légitime de l'ensemble de la
formation exigeante qu'elle reçoiv à
cette fin formation je le rappelle sur 5
ans l'adoption de cet article
additionnel après l'article 19 par la
commission des affaires sociales
constitue un premier pas en ce sens
celui prévoyant la reconnaissance du
diplôme d'État de sag-femme au niveau
master cet article est donc
véritablement positif car il permet une
habilitation du diplôme à hauteur du
nombre d'années effectué et met la
formation des sages-femmes en conformité
avec le processus de Bologne mais il
reste en l'état insuffisant car ce que
ce qu'elle souhaite c'est un véritable
cursus universitaire avec toutes les
opportunités que cela comporte notamment
l'accès à la recherche c'était
précisément le sens de l'amendement
numéro 290 que j'avais déposé en
commission au nom de notre groupe et qui
visait à mettre fin à la situation
inacceptable d'une formation de
sagesfemmes qui demeure la seule filière
médicale dont les enseignements sont
dispensés en dehors de
l'université ainsi le cursus débute au
sein des universités avec la la loi que
nous avons adopté la première année de
médecine la cette fameuse L1 santé et
les quatre années suivantes se déroulent
au sein d'une école de sag-femm
hospitalière sous l'autorité d'un
conseil régional or une telle séparation
empêche tout simplement ce que nous
avons défendu lors de l'adoption de la
L1 santé à savoir le développement d'une
culture commune de santé amorcé
justement au cours de cette première
année et qui est essentielle à la
qualité des soins au contraire les
sages-femmes doivent devenir dès leur
formation de véritables partenaires des
autres professionnels médicaux afin
d'optimiser l'offre de soins et aussi de
clarifier la lisibilité des parcours de
soins on ne le dira jamais assez une
coopération interprofessionnelle
optimale constitue la clé de l'évolution
du système de soins une intégration
totale des sages-femmes dans les
universités leur permettrait également
de de bénéficier de tous les moyens que
l'université met à disposition des
étudiants un espace numérique de travail
un centre de documentation universitaire
gestion des supports de cours en ligne
ou dans un autre registre des
possibilités de mobilité internationale
j'ai pour ma part pu apprécier
l'importance d'avoir accès à tous ces
moyens et ces service en rencontrant à
plusieurs reprises la présidente du
Conseil de l'Ordre des sages-femmes du
finisterère ainsi que la directrice de
l'école des sages-femmes du CHU UBO de
Brest en effet cette école a la
particularité d'avoir choisi et acté par
sa convention de création en 2002 une
collaboration étroite avec l'UFR de
Médecine et l'Université de Brest de
Bretagne Occidentale et à ce jour cette
école fait partie des deux écoles avec
Marseille des deux seules écoles sur les
35 exist à disposer de locaux au sein de
l'université autre élément et non des
moindres cet cette intégration pardon
permettrait à la filière sag-femme
d'accéder pleinement à la recherche et
de participerer grâce à leurs
compétences à l'évolution de la médecine
dans le domaine périnatal notamment car
l'université comporte une double mission
de formation et de recherche et il est
temps que les sagesfemmes puissent y
accéder pleinement et en cela être
reconnu comme des professionnels
médicaux à part entière et ne plus
dépendre du titre 4 mais j'ai entendu
madame la ministre vos propos tout à
l'heure et nous en débatttrons
certainement ultérieurement donc madame
la ministre je précise que notre
amendement a avait été déclaré y
reccevable par la commission des
finances en application de l'article 40
et vous comprendrez donc que je me
réjouisse aujourd'hui qu'un amendement
identique en C soit présenté par le
gouvernement afin évidemment que la
demande des sages femmes ne reste pas
lettre morte donc je voterai évidemment
pour bien alors nous avons un seul
amendement qui va présenter par Madame
la
Ministre bien je crois que je vais
effectivement répondre à la fois à
l'interpellation de Madame camerman tout
à l'heure et à l'intervention de de
Madame Blondin pour l'intégration de la
formation des sages-femmes à
l'université dans le cadre du Conseil de
l'Europe vous savez la que la France est
engagée dans le processus de Bologne qui
vise à créer un espace européen de
l'enseignement supérieur via la mise en
place du processus que vous connaissez
bien on l'appelle le processus LMD
Licence Master Doctorat d'ici 2010 et
les formations de santé médicale et
paramédical sont en voie d'être
structuré sur ce modèle je vous signale
d'ailleurs qu'il y a
évidemment tout ce qui concerne la
formation mais tout ce qui concerne
aussi le statut des personnels à
l'intérieur de la fonction publique
hospitalière et la première réunion
statut sur le ces évolutions statutaires
a d'ailleurs été lancé hier au ministère
de la Santé et dans cette perspective il
est légitime comme vous l'avez dit
Madame Blondin que le niveau de
reconnaissance de la formation de
sage-femme soit le niveau master
toutefois cet amendement qui avait été
adopté par la Commission ne relève pas
du domaine de la loi et je m'engage que
d'ici 2010 par voie réglementaire et
après refonte de leur programme de
formation sur la base du LMD le diplôme
d'État de sag-femme soit reconnu au
grade de master toutefois l'ambition
d'une réforme rapide ne doit pas avoir
pour effet de déstabiliser les écoles de
sag-femme la concertation que nous nous
avons initié avec les sages-femmes sur
l'intégration de leur formation à
l'université et que nous allons
poursuivre avec l'ensemble des acteurs
concernés doit définir les modalités
concrètes de l'universitarisation des
études de sag-femme dans l'attente des
résultats de ce travail et parce que
certaines régions certaines universités
certaines écoles de sag-femm sont d'ors
et d'ors et déjà prête je privilégie une
solution applicable rapidement parce que
d'un côté il y a ceux qui disent on est
prêt il faut y aller je veux pas les
retarder et puis il y a ceux qui disent
ceux et celles qui disent bah on a
encore besoin d'un peu de temps et je
trouve qu'il serait pas très rationnel
de de ralentir tout le monde alors que
certains soient prêts sont prêt je veux
donc que chacun puisse aller à à son
rythme ceux qui sont prêts bah elles y
vont ell elles foncent dans le
dispositif LMD puis pour d'autres ce
sera peut-être un peu plus long et donc
je privilégie une solution applicable
pragmatique
qui consiste à ouvrir une alternative
pour la formation des sages-femmes à
l'université lorsque l'ensemble des
acteurs loau est d'accord pourquoi ne
pas y aller et par contre bah on laisse
souffler un peu les autres et c'est
d'ailleurs quelque chose qui va être
intéressant parce que l'évaluation en
continu de ceux qui sont prêts à aller
dans le dispositif nous permettra
d'ailleurs peut-être de piloter ce
dispositif de manière plus intelligente
en nourrissant notre réflexion pour une
intégration complète et générale de la
formation des sages-femmes à
l'université je crois que il pourrait y
avoir un assez large consensus autour du
dispositif que je vous
proposeés juste un monsieur président
pour remercier la ministre d'avoir
repris cette proposition de la
Commission et de l'avoir organisé de
façon tout à fait cohérente et qui donne
satisfaction à tous Mon le rapporteur je
pense que vous êtes favorable
complètement aux engagements que madame
le ministre avait pris dans le cadre de
nos travaux au niveau de la commission
d'affaires sociales donc c'est un VI
extrêmement favorable bien donc je mets
au voix cet amendement qui a un avis
favorable de la commission ceux qui sont
pour veulent bien lever la main
unanimité je vous
remercie maintenant toujours au 19
bis monsur fouch non le premier le 233
tombe j'ai un 123 5 que va nous
présenter madame la
ministre je veux par cet amendement 1235
r rétablir l'exclusion des actes de
chirurgie esthétique dans le champ des
actes esthétiques visés par l'article et
supprimer la clause de valorisation des
acquis de l'expérience alors je
je
je crois que là il y a quelque chose
d'assez important et si d'ailleurs vous
vous souhaitez connaître les faits
nombreux sur lesquel je m'appuie pour
cette démarche je les tiens absolument à
votre disposition je souhaite que soit
exclus du champ des actes àis esthétique
soumis à des règles d'encadrement
juridique et technique les actes de
chirurgie esthétique qui font déjà
l'objet d'un encadrement spécifique par
la loi du 4 mars 2002 relatif au droits
des malades et à la qualité du système
de santé et les décrets d'application
afférant il est également préférable de
rétablir le terme qualification à celui
de compétence puisque ce dispositif
n'existe plus par ailleurs votre
commission monsieur le Président
Monsieur le Rapporteur a introduit un
nouvel article L
1151-4 qui s'apparente à une
valorisation des acquis professionnels
or le secteur de la médecine esthétique
s'est développé sans aucune
réglementation sur les conditions
techniques de réalisation des actes
esthétiques certaines des techniques
utilisées ont donné lieu à des
complications parfois très sévères là
aussi je tiens à la disposition de la
Haute Assemblée un certain nombre de de
cas particulièrement éclairants
particulièrement dramatique d'ailleurs
pour un certain nombre de patients des
patients surtout d'ailleurs euh et
vraiment c oui ces complications très
sévères ont amené le gouvernement à
légiférer dans ce domaine un acte
esthétique n'est pas un acte de soin la
balance bénéfice risque ne serait donc
s'appliquer et aucun risque sérieux de
santé pour les personnes ayant recours à
des pratiques esthétiques n'est
tolérable donc que là vraiment euh il y
a quelque chose d'assez fondamental au
niveau des des principes il convient
désormais d'établir des règles
d'exercice précises obligatoires pour
tous en terme de formation notamment
afin de satisfaire pleinement l'objectif
général du texte visant à sécuriser les
actes esthétiques et l'amendement vise
ainsi à supprimer l'article
l151-4 pour ne pas fragiliser cet
objectif et évidemment je me tiens à ma
je tiens à votre disposition tous les
éléments qui servent à à éayer ma
démarche merci monsieur le rapporteur et
ensuite monsieur Gornac qui est un
spécialiste de l'esthétique
oui monsieur le Président donc la
commission a donné un avis de sagesse à
l'amendement du Gouvernement plutôt
positif d'ailleurs car cet amendement ne
remet pas en cause un ajout important de
la Commission à savoir l'intervention de
la Haute Autorité de Santé pour la levée
d'interdicition de certains actes jugés
dangereux donc c'est c'est une sagesse
plutôt positive monsieur
Gornac monsieur le Président Madame le
Ministre je souhaite apporter quelques
éléments au débat puisque débat il y a
concernant cet article 19 bis cet
article proposé par l'Assemblée
nationale a été modifié par notre
commission des affaires sociales à la
suite d'un amendement que j'avais
proposé dans chacun des exposés des
motifs côté gouvernement comme côté
Parlement il est clair qu'il s'agit ici
d'encadrer une médecine esthétique qui
se développe nous parlons bien de
médecine esthétique et non pas de
chirurgie
esthétique celle-ci fait déjà l'objet
d'un dispositif d'encadrement spécifique
depuis la loi du 4 mars 2002 relative au
au droits des malades et à la qualité du
système de santé et plus précisément
depuis ses décrets d'application de 2005
nous traitons donc bien uniquement ici
dans cet article 19 bis de médecine
esthétique et c'est telle qui doit être
encadrée d'ailleurs en rajoutant une
précision que notre commission avait
supprimé le gouvernement ne fait
qu'insister sur le fait qu'il s'agit
bien avec cet article 19 bis des actes à
visé esthétique je ne peux donc qu'être
favorable à ce rajout en revanche je
pense qu'il convient puisqu'il s'agit de
médecine esthétique de parler de
compétences plutôt que de qualification
et je vais même le même le gouvernement
vous le propose d'ailleurs je vais vous
le lire dans une minute la médecine
esthétique n'étant pas une qualification
à proprement parl c'est-à-dire au sens
que revit ce terme dans les disciplines
médicales au aussi conviendrait-il de
maintenir ce thème n'est-on pas une
qualification la médecine esthétique
existe cependant bien entendu une
compétence une compétence c'est pourquoi
j'avais par mon amendement adopté en
commission proposé à d'ajouter à
l'article L
1154-4 au Code de la Santé publ publique
précisant qu'un décret fixerait les
conditions dans lesquelles les
professionnels de santé qui pratiquent
des actes avis esthétique peuvent les
poursuivre n'oublions pas qu'avec cet
article nous légiférons pour encadrer
une médecine esthétique qui existe qui
innove et qui n'est en rien une
chirurgie soyons réalistes et soucieux
de la sécurité de nos
concitoyens de nombreux médecins
exercent discipline il faut donc que le
texte précise des conditions dans
lesquelles ils peuvent être autorisés à
poursuivre cette discipline en plein
essort ou ne pas être autorisé revenir
sur la rédaction de la Commission et
reprendre de l'Assemblée nationale c'est
au moins C moins ambitieux dans la
défense d'une pratique médicale de
qualité pourquoi je dis que j'ai trouvé
dans les arguments du gouvernement objet
alors devant la prolifération des
pratiques c'est un deuxème cet acte
exthétique doiv être réalisé dans des
conditions qui ne puissent susciter
aucun doute sur la compétence sur la
compétence c'est-à-dire que dans les
exposés du motif gouvernement c'est bien
le mot compétence qui est avancé et non
pas qualification donc je le dis madame
le ministre je regrette vivement
qu'après un accord qu'on avait pris avec
vos services aujourd'hui on revienne oui
oui si si si si Madame le Ministre quand
je quand je dis les choses je je les dit
d'une façon transparente et véritable
qu'on est changé après avoir donné un
accord sur le mot compétenence que vous
reprenez d'ailleurs pour revenir
aujourd'hui pour nous dire qualification
bien
alors Monsieur co pour explication de
vote en ce qui me concerne je suis assez
favorable plutôt favorable à
l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement par Madame la Ministre
parce que je crois effectivement que
dans ce domaine il faut qu'il y ait une
certaine
régulation c'est vrai que c'est là un
peu où je je comprends pas tellement le
l'argument de notre collègue Gournac
c'est que aujourd'hui il y a une
qualification de médecine avisé
esthétique les les médecins tout le
monde sait que dans la médecine générale
jamais la médecine visisé esthétique n'a
été enseigné hein ou alors c'est tout à
fait nouveau euh donc il y a une
qualification qui s'est faite récemment
et bon qui permet d'avoir un minimum de
de données et de pratiques dans ce
domaine qui n'est pas sans danger comme
l'a dit madame la ministre je je je
dirais aussi à madame la ministre que et
le gouvernement ferait bien de regarder
d'un peu près du moins par par par le
biais des secteurs qui sont les siens
certaines pratiques dans les instituts
esthétique où on vend où on vend
notamment en matière d'amigrissement
des des des demiheures et des tro quart
d'heures de machines qui me
paraissent bon dangereuses et qui sont
une véritable escroquerie il faut bien
le dire pratiqué de manière bon large
notamment dans le secteur de
l'île-defance bien alors je vais mettre
au voix l'amendement madamem
excusez-moi je amendement de sagesse que
vous nous proposez car je crois qu'il
est indispensable effectivement
d'encadrer ces ces pratiques moi-même
j'avais déposé un amendement allons plus
loin sur la chirurgie esthétique alors
je sais très bien que vous l'avez exclu
parce que elle fait l'objet d'un
dispositif d'encadrement spécifique je
pense que il est important aussi
de ne pas l'ettre et de pouvoir être
très vigilant sur tout ce domain de la
chirurgie
esthétique je crois que tout le monde
est d'accord je vais donc mettre au voie
le 1235 ceux qui sont favorblesadoption
ve bien lever la
main je ne vois pas d'avis contraire il
y a des
abstentions pardon avis contraire ou
abstention abstention monsieur gourac le
spécialiste voilà bien l'amendement est
adopté maintenant j'aborde l'article 19
un amendement 1237 du
gouvernement
euh c'est un amendement qui veut
mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs préciser encadrer les
compétences dévolu aux ordres médicaux
je veux à la fois optimiser le
fonctionnement des ordres médicaux et
pharmaceutiques mais également euh leur
donner les moyens nécessaires pour
accomplir efficacement leur mission en
matière disciplinaire nous en avons déjà
beaucoup parlé cet après-midi et de
contrôle des compétences et des
conditions d'exercice des praticiens
ainsi inscrit au tableau c'est pourquoi
je vous propose cet amendement qui a
pour objet de rappeler les conditions de
retrait d'une décision illégale
d'inscription au tableau préciser les
modalités de radiation des praticiens ne
remplissant plus en raison de la
survenance de fait postérieur à leur
inscription les conditions pour exercer
la profession je souhaite également
donner aux ordres médicaux garant de la
déontologie de la profession de pouvoir
traduire devant les juridictions
disciplinaires les Prat icien qui
concluraient des contrats comportant des
clauses contraires à la déontologie cela
a déjà été accepté pour les pharmaciens
par ailleurs votre commission a
introduit une restriction en ce qui
concerne les poursuites disciplinaires
pour les praticiens exerçant une mission
de contrôle je vous propose de préciser
que cescision ces dispositions
dérogatoires ne s'appliquent que pour
les seuls actes exercés à l'occasion de
leur fonction euh de de ces fonctions de
contrôle car certains praticiens
exercent par ailleurs des fonctions de
soin pour lesquelles il est normal
qu'ils soi soumis au même dispositif que
leur confrère je pense que cette
précision ne rencontrera pas
d'opposition de votre rapporteur enfin
dernier point l'amendement précise que
le Conseil régional ou interrégional des
ordres médicaux est consulté par le
directeur général de l'agence régionale
de santé sur les questions et les
projets qui relèvent de ces compétences
vous vous souvenez que j'en avais pris
l'engagement devant vous lors de
l'examen du titre sur les ARS et je
remplis donc la promesse que je vous
avais faite à cette
occasion de précision utile monsieur le
Président et la commission a donné un
avis favorable bien et le Sénat est
d'accord pour voter cet amendement pas
d'objection il est adopté maintenant
j'appelle le 508 de
Monsieur il en a deux d'ailleurs on va
présenter l'un après l'autre
à entendre madame la ministre et et
l'amendement qui vient d'être voté là je
me demande si il n'est pas
satisfait
donc je le retire et le 507 qui avait
pour objet de supprimer le 12 de cet
article qu'en pensez-vous
oui alors ça c'est c'est un petit peu
différent en tout cas il est pas autre
chose c'est d'autre chose oui alors
l'article L
4124-4 du code de la santé publique que
le gouvernement entend supprimer ici
prévoit la tenue de registre de
délibération dans les chambes
disciplinaires de première instanceces
des ordres professionnels la rédaction
l'approbation et la signature de procès
verbaux à l'issue de chaque séance ainsi
le cas échant de procèsverbaux
d'interrogatoire ou d'audition signées
par les personnes interrogées nous
proposons de revenir sur cet aspect de
la disposition et de maintenir dans le
code l'obligation de tenir un registre
dans les chambres disciplinaires de
première instance des ordres
professionnels il en va du maintien de
l'obligation de transparence imposée aux
ordres professionnels et de la
protection de tous ceux qui pourrai être
traduits devant eux je ne pense pas que
cet amendement soit déjà satisfait ou
alors j'ai mal lu on va demander l'avis
de la
commission c'est sur le 507 oui oui
monsieur le Président le ces alinéas
n'ont jamais été respectés mon cher
collègue ils impliquerit une violation
du secret du délibéré en outre même le
code de justice administrative n'impose
pas aux juridictions administratives de
droit commun d'établir des PV de
témoignage recueillis en cours
d'audition c'est donc un avis
défavorable quel est l'avis du
Gouvernement oui bien entendu je je
partage le le souit de Monsieur
hatin d'une nécessaire
transparence pour respecter les droits
de la défense toutefois les modalités de
fonctionnement et de procédure que doit
respecter la chambre disciplinaire de
première instance sont tout à fait
définis dans la partie réglementaire du
code de la santé publique euh depuis
2007 et donc elle ceci s'établit dans la
partie réglementaire des articles R 41
26 1 à 41 26 54 pour le 41
26-26 il prévoit que les affaires sont
examinées en audience publique pour le
41 2618 que le rapporteur doit adresser
un procès verbal de chaque audition qui
est versé au dossier et communiqué au
parti et l'article R 41 26 33 définit
les conditions de notification des
décisions rendues par les chambres
disciplinaires et l'article 41 26 37
prévoit leur publicité par voie
d'affichage vous voyez que cette partie
réglementaire du code de la santé
publique
est marqué par le souci d'informer de
respecter le principe du contradictoire
et par conséquent le maintien de
l'article L 41 244 du code de la santé
publique n'est plus indispensable pour
assurer la nécessaire transparence des
droits et et ainsi respecter les droits
de la défense donc il y a un remodelage
mais n'ayez crainte monsieur hatin ce
que vous souhaitez est bien mis dans
dans le code et c'est pour éviter cette
redondance maintenant inutile depuis
2007 que nous avons av pris cette
disposition monsieurtin est sous votre
charme je l'écoute avec beaucoup
d'attention
et comme pour le précédent
donc mais donc il y a une une régression
dans la hiérarchie des normes puisque
c'estàdire qu'on passe du législatif en
règlementaire et pour quelle raison oui
c'est une c'est dommage enfin si vous me
dites que ces conditions seront toujours
respectées je je retire mon amendement
je vous remercie monsieurtin et
monsieurtin par anticipation avait
retirer le 571 tout à l'heure
l'amendement numéro 27 rectifié de
Monsieur darnich tombe j'appelle le 78
de Monsieur
Lamini merci monsieur le Président
Madame la Ministre chers collègu donc
amendement conjoint avec collègue
Huré donc au niveau du du du code de la
santé publique bon avec l'insertion d'un
d'un paragraphe indiqué comme suit les
fonctions de président ou de trésorier
d'un des conseils de l'ordre et l'une
quelconque des fonctions correspondantes
d'un syndicat pharmaceutique sont
incompatibles je ne veux pas reprendre
l'objet hein comme vous l'avez sur sur
cet amendement numéro
donc pour l'article 19 terre avec donc
l'insertion de ce
paragraphe voilà merci de votre
concision et j'appelle l'avis du
rapporteur monsieurz écouté monsieur le
Président cette précision donnée par
notre collègue Laménie a paru utile à la
commission donc elle souhaite néanmoins
entendre le gouvernement et elle donne
un avis de sagesse parfait madame la
ministre votre avis
je veux dire à Monsieur Laménie que je
ne suis pas favorable à son amendement
je vais lui expliquer pourquoi c'est
parce que certes les pharmaciens sont
des professionnels de santé et que mais
ils sont aussi des chefs
d'entreprise c'est la la
caractéristique de de cette profession
qui a été la mienne et que véritablement
ça ne vaut d'ailleurs que pour la
section des pharmaciens d'officine
véritablement il ne doit y avoir aucune
confusion entre les les fonctions
syndicales et les fonctions ordinales
autant pour d'autres professions
pharmaceutiques ou d'autres professions
euh de santé ça peut s'expliquer ça peut
se concevoir autant vraiment pour les
pharmaciens d'officine je demande qu'il
a une étanchéité totale entre les
fonctions syndicales et les fonctions
ordinales car c'est vraiment la
profession où il y a profession de santé
chef
d'entreprise
merci euh que faites-vous vous monsieur
Lamini bon je pense qu'il reti mais
j'aimis bien qu'il me le dise
contenuexplication du ministre merci
monsieur le Président bon compte tenu
aussi de l'avis bon du rapporteur bon un
avis de sagesse mais euh au vu des
informations de de Madame la Ministre et
comp tenu bon différentes informations
je dirais donc euh je vais donc retirer
cet amendement numéro 78
bien je vous remercie alors l'article 19
t ainsi modifié euh je le mets au voix
même vote vous êtes d'accord pour
l'adopter il est adopté j'arrive au 19
quat j'ai un 509 du président
ficher
alors il s'agit par cet article bon
d'adapter les modes de fonctionnement
d'un certain nombre d'ordres alors par
contre notre amendement que nous vous
proposons d'adopter vise à supprimer le
grand de cet article introduit à
l'Assemblée nationale et conservé par
notre commission qui permet à l'Ordre
national des infirmiers de disposer des
listes nominatives des infirmiers
employés par des structures publiques ou
privées en vue notamment de procéder à
leur inscription automatique à l'ordre
alors cette disposition me rappelle le
débat que nous avions eu ici même dans
le cadre de la proposition de loi sur la
création de l'Ordre Infirmier que nous
avions combattu nous avions voté contre
au cours de ce débat en octobre 2006
nous anticipions certainement sur ce
nouveau mauvais tour que vous jouez à
ces professionnels lorsque nous disons
pourquoi devrai-il tous adhérer à une
instance qui risque de sur sur cro de se
révéler un outil de surveillance et de
contrainte supplémentaire au lieu d'un
outil de défense des droits ah bah
attendez écoutez mais il y a un
déséquilibre terrible terrible vous
savez bien il doit y avoir 14000
infirmières libérales et puis plusieurs
centaines de milliers de
d'hospitalière voilà obligé de cotiser
et cetera c'est ça le libéralisme vous
imposez alors
oui oui il a raison il a
raison alors pourquoi
pourquoi devrait-il tous adhérer à une
instance qui risque de se surcroit se
révéler un outil de surveillance etette
contrainte supplémentaire au lieu d'un
outil de défense des droits alors si
l'obligation est obligatoire elle met en
cause le libre droit de se syndquer ou
d'adhérer à une association quelconque
qu'est-ce qui justifie une telle mise en
cause des libertés fondamentales mais
oui madame la ministre écoutez moi j'ai
beaucoup d'amis qui sont infirmiers
hospitaliers ils n'entendent absolument
pas adhérer à l'Ordre national des
infirmiers c'est ça notre crainte et
celle des infirmiers des personnels
infirmiers s'avérrait malheureusement
fondé puisque'avec cette disposition
vous renforcez un autoritarisme
intolérable sur les infirmières et les
infirmiers hospitaliers notamment alors
je voudrais par d'ailleurs par ailleurs
souligner que ce transfert de
coordonnées et d'identité de personnes
classées oserai-je dire ficher en raison
de leur activité professionnelle
pourrait être sanctionné par la
Commission nationale de l'informatique
et des libertés c'est un dossier que
nous suivons le président de laacnil
notre collègue Alex Turk faisait
d'ailleurs dans le rapport annuel de
l'institution la mère constat selon
lequel plus aucun secteur d'activité
plus aucune parcelle de notre vie
individuelle et collective n'échappe
désormis au développement et à la
pression des technologies nouvelles de
l'information très récemment à
l'occasion d'une question orale que j'ai
déposé sur le
RNCPS répertoire national commun de la
protection sociale nous dénoncions la
volonté du gouvernement d'utiliser les
technologies informatiqu de plus en plus
puissante on va connecter je vous disais
65 fichiers et de plus en plus puissant
et performant au détriment de la liberté
des personnes du respect de leur
intimité et de leur vie privée alors
tout à l'heure c'était contre les
Rmistes et ceux qui bénéficieront du RSA
là ce sera contre les infirmière donc le
gouvernement comme notre commission
persiste dans cette obsession du fichage
et ajoute à la contrainte de
l'inscription à l'ordre une mesure
vexatoire et attentatoire au respect de
la vie privée bon j'exagère peut-être
j'ai peut-être dépassé le trait mais je
ne suis pas loin de la vérité pas loin
de la vérité alors on va demander l'avis
de la
commission donc oui monsieur leés
prident l'article 19 quat a permis au au
groupe CRC SPG de réaffirmer ses
positions constantes depuis 2006
c'està-dire depuis la loi sur l'ordre
des infirmiers ce qui nous permet à nous
de réaffirmer nos position constante
depuis cette époque là et de donner un
avis défavorable à son
amendement bien Madame le Ministre votre
avis je pense qu'il doit être assez
proche du rapporteur oui bien sûr je
connais
l'argumentation je connais l'opposition
de Monsieur cher à la création de
l'Ordre de l'Ordre
Infirmier c'est un débat qui peut
utilement peut-être être ressuscité si
je puis dire je trouve que aujourd'hui
il utilise une argumentation dont
lui-même convient qu'elle n'est
peut-être pas entièrement fondé
oui j'ai tort du provoquer monsieur
ficher je vais susciter une une réponse
je je veux simplement vous rappeler
qu'il s'agit pour l'ordre de disposer de
donneré lui permettant d'exercer sa
mission de service public bon si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord avec la création de
l'Ordre je le je comprends mais restons
restons simple en l'espèce et et ainsi
permettre le contrôle de la légalité de
l'exercice des
infirmiers la transmission alors des
listes nominatives des infirmiers
employés par les structures publiques et
privées et conforme aux dispositions
prévues par la loi Informatique et
Liberté dès lors qu'elle est prévue dans
la loi et que les personnes concernées
en sont informées on ne se situe pas
dans le cadre de la réutilisation de
données
publiques il s'agit au contraire pour
l'ordre de disposer des moyens d'exercer
sa mission de service public et je
m'engage à rappeler aux employeurs
publics et privés l'obligation qui leur
impose de respecter les dispositions
prévues par la loi Informatique et
Liberté concernant l'établissement des
fichiers de professionnels par ailleurs
en ce qui concerne l'utilisation de ces
listes nominatives votre commission des
affaires sociales a proposé d'en
sécuriser les conditions de mise en
œuvre par décret sohait que je partage
voilà j'ai voulu à Monsieur ficher
rappeler un certain nombre de choses
très très concrètes sur cela et il
l'assurer qu'on peut ne pas être
d'accord avec la création de l'Ordre
Infirmier pour des raisons X ou Y mais
que la protection des données
personnelles est assurée bon pour
explication de vote président Co
oui monsieur le Président je je
profite de la
l'amendement de nos collègues CRC pour
donner la position du groupes
socialiste sur ce problème effectivement
nous nous voterons en faveur de cet
amendement de nos
collègues en effet la la la question des
ordres est une question récurrente et
notre position n'a pas changé les
infirmiers qui ont fait le choix
d'exercer leur activité en qualité de
fonctionnaire du secteur hospitalier se
voi non seulement obligé de s'inscrire
un ordre professionnel alors qu'il
dispose de statut et conventions
collectives qui précise des
règles d'un certain nombre de règles
encadrant les conditions d'exercice de
de leur activité mais aussi se voit
imposer de régler de de ce fait une
cotisation fixée depuis avril à 75 €.
euh d'ailleurs montant qui semble en en
complète contradiction avec le projet
initial et les propos que vous auriez
tenu madame la ministre enfin bref sur
le caractère automatique de
l'inscription le groupe socialiste a
déposé un amendement là dans ce sens de
la suppression de cet automatisme pour
les masseurs Kin thérapeutes du secteur
public notre soutien à cet amendement
euh de nos collègues en direction des
infirmières s'inscrit en ce sens je ne
reprendrai pas de manière complète les
arguments déjà
développés mais il paraît inapproprié de
de systématiser l'inscription de
professionnel à un ordre qui pour
certains d'entre eux n'est qu'un niveau
supplémentaire et inutile de pression
déontologique ou disciplinaire
supplémentaire lors des élections du 25
novembre 2008 rappelons-le les
professionnels concernés ont d'ailleurs
exprimé par leur abstention massive leur
désaveux de cette cet organisme du fait
notamment de son manque de
représentativité voilà en quelques mots
dans une période d'érosion du pouvoir
d'achat par ailleurs ce pourraêtre ceci
pourrait apparaître comme un nouveau
mode contraint d'amputation de ce
pouvoir d'achat de ces professionnel
pourquoi ne pas faire en sorte de
réviser ce montant ou ces conditions de
paiement et même d'envisager comme c'est
demandé dans
l'amendement que la cotisation ordinale
soit basée sur le vol
bien je vous remercie donc je vais
mettre au voit l'amendement de Monsieur
htin ceux qui sont favorableoption
veulent bien lever la
main quels sont ceux qui sont dans avis
contraire l'amendement n'est pas adopté
j'aborde le 1278 du
gouvernement c'est un amendement un peu
long en rédaction parce que il toilette
un certain nombre de de dispositions
mais il est plus simple rassurez-vous à
présenter euh je je veux par cet
amendement renforcer le fonctionnement
des ordres paramédicaux leur
installation récente harmoniser les
dispositions qui leur sont applicables
alors d'abord je souhaite aligner les
missions des conseils départementaux de
l'Ordre Infirmier sur celle des autres
euh ordres paramédicaux en ce qui
concerne l'inscription tableau et
centrer les missions de l'Ordre des
Infirmiers sur ces missions initial qui
sont les missions ordinales
traditionnell et étendu alors c'est il y
a une certaine confusion qui a été
introduite par la promotion de la santé
publique qui est une mission qui incombe
au pouvoir public en premier lieu au
ministère de la Santé qui s'appuie bien
entendu pour mener cette politique de
santé publique sur un nombre de sur un
certain nombre de partenaires
institutionnels et bien sûr les ordres
des professions de santé sont appelés à
appuyer ces action sont nos partenaires
habituels mais euh les la mission
essentielle d'un ordre est autre et
ajouter aux missions de l'ordre la
promotion de la santé publique et la
qualité des soins est vraiment source de
dispersion de confusion du rôle des uns
et des autres ça c'est le premier point
le le deuxième point je veux et comme
vient d'ailleurs de le souhaiter
monsieur casazo dans son intervention
liminire je souhaite étendre la
possibilité de moduler la le montant de
la cotisation à l'Ordre national des
infirmiers c'est d'ailleurs une
possibilité qui est dors et déjà ouverte
aux autres ordres nationaux paramédicaux
et cette possibilité de modulation
répondra aux attentes de la profession
majoritairement salarié donc ça c'est le
deuxème point qui devrait recueillir un
un assez large un assez large appui
troisème point l'amendement prévoit que
les conditions d'inscription
automatiques des pédicures podologues au
tableau de l'Ordre se font dans des
conditions fixées par décret c'est déjà
la le processus qui est adopté pour les
infirmiers et pour les masseurs qui
n'ésitent thérapeutes 4è point
l'amendement vise à assurer la
consultation obligatoire des conseils
nationaux des ordres paramédicaux par
l'UNCAM sur les dispositions
conventionnelles relatives à la
déontologie c'est déjà prévu pour les
ordres médicaux c'est souhaitable que
cela soit pour les ordres paramédicaux
et c'est une mesure qui est très
attendue par les ordres concernés enfin
5è point l'amendement propose
d'autoriser le regroupement pour chaque
ordre de conseil départementaux de
l'Ordre des infirmiers des bceur kinis
thérapeutes et des conseils régionaux de
l'ordre des pédicures podologu lorsque
la faiblesse des effectifs ou la
situation démographique des profess oui
démographique des professions rend
difficile le fonctionnement des
instances ordinales locales en effet si
la plupart de ces structures
fonctionnent bien une minorité d'entre
elles rencontre ou pourrai rencontrer
des problèmes d'organisation compte tenu
d'un nombre insuffisant de conseillers
ordinaux élus qu'il soi titulairire ou
suppléant je prendre un exemple l'ordre
des masseur quiinésit
thérapeute prévoit pour l'avenir des
difficultés dans certains départements
en particulier dans les Alpes de Haute
Provence et la Corse pour lesquels des
solutions de mutualisation de moyens ou
de regroupement pourrait être recherché
à son initiative sur la base de cet
amendement nous ne souhaitons pas
imposer nous souhaitons pouvoir donner
la possibilité pour ces instances
d'opérer de tels regroupements
permettant donc la mutualisation des
moyens voilà ce que je vous propose par
cet amendement
1278 téléphone est interdit en séance
euh monsieur le
rapporteur non non c'est pas vous madame
le ministre je le dirai a plus de Nuan
si c'est vous l'amendement é
téléphoné non non non
non euh donc monsieur le Président chers
collègu l'objet donc ces
diverses précisions sur les ordres
professionnels paramédicaux la
commission madame le ministre a émis un
avis défavorable au grand 1 et au grand
2 de votre amendement qui reviennent sur
les dispositions souhaitées par la
commission pour confier à l'ordre un
rôle en matière de promotion de santé
publique et de la qualité des soins par
contre elle a mis un avis de sagesse
positive sur les autres paragraphes qui
permettent notamment les regroupements
interdépartementaux si les effectifs des
professions des élus ordinau ordinaux le
justifie donc le 1 et le 2 défavorable
par la Commission en vote et le le reste
favorable un vote par division ça sera
le plus simple si vous en êtes d'accord
hein monsieurf vous avez demandé la
parole c'est sur cet amendement là bien
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre concernant cette cet
amendement nous aurions peut-être
préféré que l'amendement déposé à
l'Assemblée nationale par monsieur Bur
fasse l'objet d'un examin plus attentif
en effet cette cet amendement prévoyait
que l'échelon régional était
certainement plus satisfaisant
concernant l'Ordre des Masseurs kinésit
thérapeutes alors ça peut se discuter
c'est une question je j'avais soulevé
d'ailleurs en commission mais il
semblerait que d'ailleurs dans votre
texte madame la ministre vous compreniez
bien cette affaire puisque les conseils
départementaux pourront effectivement se
regrouper mais peut-être que
l'amendement qui avait été voté à
l'Assemblée nationale était peut-être
plus pertinent c'est-à-dire de
reconnaître les champs régionales
d'autant plus que c'est une question de
démographie pour ce qui concerne les
massurs kinis thérapeutes puisque ça
environ 100000 personnes pour des
départements comme le mien c'est
véritablement un chiffre très faible et
on pense que il serait mieux que le
regroupement se fasse au niveau de la R
région basse-enormandie par contre par
contre je crois qu'il faut il faut
certainement aussi s'interroger sur
l'évolution parce que je crois savoir
que le le juge administratif est saisi
concernant les compositions du Conseil
national et des échelons départementaux
de de de de de l'Ordre des Masseurs CLIS
thérapeutes je crois que il faudra
peut-être y revenir enfin en tout état
de cause il me semble que pour des
régions comme celle que je connais bien
l'échelon régional était certainement le
plus pertinent par ailleurs on y
reviendra tout à l'heure aussi mais je
voudrais rappeler que comme pour leur
droit des infirmierers le problème donc
des m kinési thérapeutes on peut
s'étonner voir s'indigner que les
personnes qui sont salariées soient
obligé de cotiser c'est une obligation
de cotisation pour travailler nous
l'avions dit à l'époque nous renouvelons
je trouve que c'est tout à fait
inacceptable qu'il y ait une adhésion
volontaire si on veut créer un ordre
peut-être l'obligation l'obligation
d'adhérer pour des salariés me semble
une obligation de de comme d'obliger
d'adhérer à un syndicat ou une
association et ça me semble tout à fait
anormal et d'ailleurs on va y revenir
peut-être tout à l'heure mais il faut
savoir que dans nos hôpitaux les massurs
k thérapeutes salariés se tournent vers
les conseils d'administration qui ne
peuvent rien faire en demandant de bien
vouloir payer leur cotisation donc je
crois que à l'époque nous avions mis le
doigt sur ce problème là comme pour les
ordres infirmiers et je pense que le
problème n'est pas réglé encore
aujourd'hui monsieur
barvier
ou monsieur le Président moi je
soutiendrai le l'amendement du
Gouvernement parce que je pense que le
le 1 bis apporte des précisions qui sont
une description de compétenence de
moralité et d'indépendance c'est
précisément le rôle des ordres que ce
soit l'ordre national des infirmiers ou
des médecins ou des chirurgiens
dentistes ou et le deuxè
alinéa concernant comme l'a souligné
madame le ministre je ne pense pas que
le Conseil national de l'ordre des que
l'Ordre national des infirmiers a un
rôle à jouer sur la promotion de la
santé publique et de la qualité des
soins il est là pour surveiller la
déontologie des infirmiers en général et
ne le chargeons pas d'une mission qui
n'aura certainement pas les moyens de
remplir donc personnellement je pense
que l'amendement présenté par le
gouvernement correspond un peu plus à la
réalité et calque l'ordre
des infirmiers sur les autres ordres
nationaux bien alors mes chers collègues
je demande beaucoup d'attention le 1278
du gouvernement nous allons procéder au
vote de cet amendement par division
comme l'a souhaité la commission d'abord
le 1 et le 2 pour lequel le gouvernement
souhaite la suppression et pour laquelle
la Commission est d'un avis défavorable
donc ceux qui sont favorables à la
position du gouvernement veulent bien
lever la
main
3 avis
contraire alors
compter il n'est pas
adopté nous reprenons la discussion du
projet de loi adopté par l'Assemblée
nationale après déclaration d'urgence
portant réforme de l'hôpital et relatif
au patients à la santé et au territoire
dans la discussion des article nous
sommes parvenus à l'article 19
sex nous avons d'abord des amendements
qui font l'objet d'une discussion
communes trois amendements le
premier monsieur Lecler le premier tombe
le
rectifié doit tomberé
également le
870 monsieur monsieur
blanc vous avez la parole chers
collègues
oui
oui monsieur le Président cet article
cet amendement vise à supprimer
l'article 19
sex parce que cet article autorise
l'Inspection générale des affaires
sociales à accéder au Cabinet des
médecins des bureaux pour les
contrôler nous considérons que cela
constitue voocation doit être supprimé
car
elle entraînerait peut-être des des
déviances de la médecine
libérale merci chers collègues monsieur
le rapporteur quel est l'avis de la
commission sur cet amendement 870 alors
je vais être bref monsieur le Président
autant que Monsieur blanc pour dire que
l'avis de la commission est défavorable
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre défavorable éal
défavorable pas de demande d'explication
de vote vote que ceux qui souhaitent
adopter cet amendement veillent bien
le il est
retiré numéro amendement
872 il est défendu par Monsieur Derot
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre l'article L 14 211 du code de
la santé publique fixe la liste des lois
et règlements dont l'application est
contrôlée par les services d'inspection
sanitaire de l'État il convient
d'élargir ce contrôle à l'ostéopathie et
à la chyropraxie afin de rendre effectif
le contrôle des établissement de
formation d'ostéopathie et de
chirropraxie confié notamment aux
représentants de l'État dans la région
par l'article 19 què par ailleurs cette
extension vise également à garantir la
qualité des soins en permettant le
contrôle sur le terrain des
professionnels ce que réclamit tout à
l'heure d'ailleurs notre collègue
gofroid ça va donc bien dans le même
sens c'est le l'objet de cet amendement
monsieur le Président merci chers
collègu monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la commission monsieur le Président
c'est une précision utile donc avis
favorable merci Madame la Ministre
favorable favorable pas d'explication de
vote que ceux qui souhaitent adopter cet
amendement veuillent bien lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont compre
veent bien lever la main il est
adopté vote sur l'article 19 sex 6 pas
de demande d'explication de vote que
ceux qui souhaitent l'adopter veuilleent
bien le lever la main merci que ceux qui
sont contre veent bien lever la main il
est
adopté rapporteur nous avons nous en
arrivons donc à l'article 20 j'ai une
demande de prise de parole de monsieur
le
rapporteur monsieur le Président merci
elle va être courte mais l'article 20
comporte l'habilitation du gouvernement
à conduire la réforme de la biologie
médicale mes chers collègues l'enjeu est
double avoir la meilleure qualité
d'examen impossible et préserver le
caractère médical de l'exercice de cette
profession qui ne doit pas être soumise
au droit de la concurrence que pourrait
imposer la Cour de justice des
Communautés européennes le gouvernement
a mené depuis plusieurs mois un travail
important sur la base du rapport balerau
et ce qui est suffisamment rare pour
être souligné madame la ministre a
communiqué à l'ensemble des commissaires
le projet d'ordonnance des commissaires
de la commission des affaires
sociales nous pouvons donc débattre de
manière pleinement informée et ceci a pu
apaiser certaines
craintes merci monsieur le rapporteur
madame la ministre
oui mesdames les sénatrices messieurs
les sénateurs je ne vais pas revenir
d'une manière très détaillée sur la
réforme de la biologie médical que je
vous propose nous aurons l'occasion d'en
discuter au travers des amendements je
veux vous dire que la voie retenue est
celle d'une médicalisation renforcée de
cette discipline absolument indispens
et qui va nous permettre d'avoir une
biologie médicale de
qualité une seule modalité est possible
c'est bien celle de de
l'accréditation qui se place dans des
procédures européennes volontairement
non commerciales c'est une réforme
urgente attendu nous avons une biologie
médicale de qualité mais qui peut
montrer parfois des ruptures ou des
insuffisances auxqueles il convient de
remédier et c'est une réforme qui a été
construite pour les
patients j'ai choisi
une une formule c'est celle de la
procédure de l'ordonnance législative
alors je sais bien mesdames et messieurs
les sénateurs et sénatrices monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président ce
n'est pas la voie que le Parlement
préfère mais elle est adaptée à cette
réforme structurelle parce que cette
réforme constitue un ensemble cohérent
largement concerté totalement
transparent le rapporteur a fait appel
euh à à le aux travaux de la commission
balerau effectivement tous les
commissaires qui l'ont souhaité euh tous
les parlementaires pardon commissaires
aussi de la commission desers mais tous
les parlementaires qui l'ont souhaité
ont été invités à participé au groupes
de travail qui ont été constitués tous
les groupes politiques qui ont été les
bienvenus et c'est dans cet esprit que
j'ai communiqué à votre commission des
affaires sociales le projet actuel
d'ordonnance qui mérite sans doute des
ajustements en outre cette ordonnance
devra être ratifiée explicitement par le
Parlement ce n'est donc pas un blancin
que vous me donnez que vous donnez au
gouvernement c'est une marque de
reconnaissance que vous donnez aux
biologistes et aux acteurs qui se sont
pleinement engagé dans cette réforme et
que je veux d'ailleurs
remercier merci madame la ministre
monsieur
Leclaire merci monsieur le Président
permettez-moi à mon tour d'ajouter
quelques mots avant justement d'examiner
les l'ensemble des amendements relatifs
donc à cet article 20 et qui concerne la
biologie et je voudrais rapidement
rappeler quelques grands principes et
vous le savez très bien me tienent à
cœur tout d'abord l'excellent rapport de
Michel ballerau est une contribution
essentielle à nos réflexions et a
largement inspiré donc le projet des
ordonnances prévues à l'issue de la loi
HPST et madame le ministre vous avez
bien voulu nous en remettre un
exemplaire en commission il y a quelques
temps alors tout d'abord je tiens à
réaffirmer solenellement que la biologie
concernée par la loi bien évidemment que
nous examinons est une spécialité
médicale elle participe à la prévention
au diagnostic et au suivi thérapeutique
des maladies des
patients comme toute spécialité médicale
elle est exercée par des médecins et des
pharmaciens biologistes et ce après une
longue formation spécifique
complémentaire et reconnu nécess ser
dans toute l'Europe pour exercer ce
métier en Europe ils sont désignés sous
un nom générique de
biopathologiste deuxièmement la médecine
libérale en France est une médecine de
proximité donc la biologie médicale doit
s'inscrire dans ce même schéma et être
exercé par des biologistes proches d'une
part des patients et aussi des
prescripteurs pour une meilleure
coopération et ce au service des
patients la biologie médicale doit
participer à la permanence des soins sur
l'ensemble des territoires de santé dans
le cadre des obligations retenues par
les ARS 4rièmement les laboratoires
d'analyse médicale bien sûr doivent
obéir aux contraintes réglementaires
établies par le ministère et satisfaire
aux exigences de
qualité donc Madame le Ministre donc nos
amendements sont proposés donc pour
protéger cette spécialité médicale ces
conditions d'exercice et aussi son
avenir je répète c'est aussi une
spécialité médicale qui comme d'autres
spécialités je pense à la radiologie
nécessite des actes techniques de plus
en plus sophistiqués et
coûteux sous ce prétexte des
eurotechnocrates des financiers aussi
peu scrupuleux veulent réduire la
biologie médicale à des actes technique
et considérer cette spécialité comme une
prestation de service dans le seul but
ou le but premier de générer à court
terme des profits issus d'une
financiérisation du capital des
laboratoires et aussi d'une
industrialisation
technique bien sûr il faut que la
profession se réorganise dans un cadre
réglementaire strict mais notre rôle ce
soir est de préserver l'indépendance de
la biologie médicale en donnant au
biologistes des moyens de s'organiser
pour financer leur collaboration
professionnelle
les exigences de qualité et
l'intégration des jeunes biologistes
dans le capital des sociétés d'exercice
libérales des laboratoires donc l'un des
objets de la loi HPST doit doit être de
garantir l'exercice de la biologie
médicale par des professionnels
qualifiés pour exercer une spécialité
médicale de qualité qui contribue à la
permanence de soins sur l'ensemble des
territoires de santé en France et ce en
toute indépendance vis-à-vis des
financiers des fournisseurs mais aussi
ne l'oublions pas des gestionnaires du
risque et des prescripteurs
merci merci chers collègues prise de
parole de Monsieur Bordier s'il vous
plaît monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre notre collègue Ren beumont
avait déposé un amendement qui devait
défendre rapidement mais je crois qu'il
n'est pas encore arrivé donc je vais
prendre la la parole à ce moment de la
discussion selon le rapport balerau qui
vient
d'être cité l'accès des docteurs
vétérinaires au diplôme d'études
spécialisé de biologie médicale serait
interdit les excluant ainsi de la
biologie
médicale les vétérinaires biologieses
sont amenés dans le cadre de leur
activité professionnelle spécialisé à
intervenir dans la chaîne de diagnostic
et de prévention des
oses en luttant pour leur éradication
dès leur apparition chez l'animal la
menace de grippe avière l'émergence de
nouvelles maladies en lien avec le
réchauffement climatique West n par
exemple montre toute l'importance du
rôle du vétérinaire biologiste faut-il
rappeler l'apport des vétérinaires dans
la lutte contre les maladies humaines
Camille Guérin mise au point du BCG avec
Albert Calmet Gaston Ramon vaccin contre
le tétanos Philippe MOPA vaccin contre
l'hépatite B faut-il rappeler aussi que
le secrétariat de défense nationale
associe dans la maîtrise des risques NBC
les vétérinaires
biologistes il n'y a pas deux biologies
la biologie humaine d'une part la
biologie animale de l'autre il n'y a
qu'une seule biologie interdire
interdire l'accès des vétérinaires à la
biologie humaine serait gravement
préjudiciable en terme de santé publique
humaine et irait à l'encontre des
coopérations pluridisciplinaires
installées depuis plus de 100 ans les
vétérinaires sont souvent le premier
rempart contre la transmission des
épisoesi enfin le deses de biologie
médicale est actuellement la seule voie
de formation de biologiste pour les
vétérinaires écarter l'accès de CS au
vétérinaires aurait pour conséquence
d'interdire toute la biologie au
vétérinaires il est essentiel de
garantir cet accès les vétérinaires ont
toutes leur place dans les structures
concernées toutes les qualités
scientifiques pour répondre à leur
attente on nous dit que la filière
n'attire que très peu de vétérinaires il
n'y a donc pas de concurrence et aucun
risque il n'y a que des avantages à
maintenir la possibilité qui existait
jusqu'à maintenant pour les vétérinaires
d'intervenir dans ce domaines merci mer
cher collègu alors nous avions trois
amendements qui font l'objet d'une
discussion commune le 871 est retiré en
séance le 119 n'est pas défendu j'en
arrive donc au 510 il est présenté par
Monsieur
Fisher alors nous abordons par cet
article 20 la réforme par d'Ordon du
statut des laboratoires de biologie
médicale et bien entendu le fait que
soit par voie
d'ordonnance nous chagrine beaucoup et
chagrine aussi en même temps je dois le
souligner notre ami Jean de cessard qui
avec d'autres sénateurs a présenté un
amendement de suppression de cet article
et je dois dire qu'il regrette vraiment
de ne pas être là
mais ouais la
pirogue donc le 23 septembre 2008 Michel
balarot vous remettez madame la ministre
un rapport sur un projet de réforme de
la biologie médicale en effet le
Gouvernement a souhaité l'an dernier
entreprendre une nouvelle réforme de la
biologie médicale la précédente datant
de
1975 alors même si nous ne pas
partageons pas la totalité des
propositions et suggestions de Monsieur
balro notamment en ce qui concerne
l'ouverture du capital des laboratoires
à des non biologistes l'ampleur du
travail effectué traduit l'ampleur de la
réforme de la biologie médicale à venir
c'est pourquoi nous déplorons le choix
du gouvernement de vouloir faire passer
cette importante réforme par voie
d'ordonnance ne laissant donc au
Parlement que la possibilité de
s'exprimer sur le projet de loi de
ratification encore faut-il que celui-ci
ne soit pas inséré dans un texte de
simplification du droit comme c'est
fréquemment le cas même si l'Assemblée
nationale a opportunément supprimé du
champ de l'habilitation
l'assouplissement des règles relatives à
la détention de capital le Parlement
n'en est pas moins légitime à pouvoir
débattre des dispositions applicables au
laboratoires publics et privés au moyen
de garantir la qualité des examens de
biologie médicale ou encore de définir
les missions du biologiste du
laboratoire et du personnel dans le
cadre du parcours de soins du patient
d'autant plus que cette définition des
missions s'inscrit dans le but d'assurer
l'efficacité des dépenses de santé alors
nous ne connaissons que trop bien les
mesures destinées à assurer l'efficacité
des dépenses de santé en général elles
se traduisent par une moins bonne prise
en charge des dépenses de santé des
patients à qui l'on demande de faire
toujours plus de sacrifices pour leur
santé c'est-à-dire de payer toujours
plus j'en veux pour preuve
l'instauration des franchises médicales
ou les déremboursements massifs de
médicaments qui se sont imposés à nous
au fil des
ans en revanche vous n'exigez pas des
laboratoires pharmaceutique par exemple
qu'il cessent de mettre sur le marché
des médicaments qui n'ont pas fait
preuve de leur efficacité thérapeutique
et qui sont pourtant remboursés par la
Sécurité sociale alors soyons clair il
est inacceptable que le Parlement ne
puisse débattre de la réforme de la
biologie médicale aucun argument pas
même celui de la technicité ne justifie
que les parlementaires ne soient saisis
d'un tel texte nous examinons
suffisamment souvent des textes
complexes et techniques pour pouvoir le
faire une fois de plus c'est pour cela
que mon groupe et moi-même demandons la
suppression de l'article
20 merci chers collègues monsieur le
rapporteur la vie de la commission
uniquement sur le 510
oui ils étaient identiques monsieur le
Président tous les deux autres donc
l'avis est le même c'est un avis
défavorable parce que la la réforme de
la biologie médicale est soumise à une
contrainte de temps imposé par la
Commission européenne et le projet
d'ordonnance qui a été distribué
rappelons-le à l'ensemble des
commissaires montre que celle-ci est
bien avancé et je pense aussi que le
Parlement aura l'occasion d'en
rediscuter lors de la ratification c'est
donc un avis défavorable mer monsieur
rapporteur madame la ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement oh j'imis un avis
défavorable la réforme de la biologie
médicale on peut en discuter des
modalités mais pensez qu'elle n'est pas
utile est effectivement un contresens au
regard des exigences de santé on regarde
des exigences de santé le débat se s'est
focalisé sur un point qui était
l'ouverture du capital et nous aurons
l'occasion effectivement de montrer que
ce point est levé je dois dire que dans
ce débat difficile nous aurions sans
doute été plus aidés si la gauche
n'avait pas permis l'ouverture de ce
capital en son temps ce qui nous a
considérablement desservi au moment de
plidder notre dossier devant les
instances européennes alors les leçons
sur l'ouverture de la capitale mesdames
et messieurs la gauche vous garder pour
vous merci Madame la
Ministre s'il n'y a y y a-t-il des
demandes d'explication de vote oui
monsieur
co bon
euh madame la ministre on va pas se
donner des leçons autrement on pourrait
se donner des leçons de
parlementarisme
puisque il faut bien le dire Artic
article 20 et 21 d'ailleurs sont
constittu des ophniis législatifs
puisqu'il y a la suppression d'ouverture
avec la suppression d'ouverture capital
que nous approuvons
demeurant l'intérêt de ces deux articles
semble bien limité il n'y a rien du
moins en apparence en effet à bien lire
en détail sur les articles tout sera
déterminé par voie d'ordonnance vous
nous l'avez dit d'ailleurs en matière de
réforme des laboratoires d'analyse de
biologie
biologie médicale bien sûr je
désapprouve fermement et nous
désapprouvons fermement ce procédé il
foule du pied la dernière réforme
constitutionnel car il est
contradictoire avec l'idée de
revaloriser le rôle du Parlement que je
vous le disais au début nous n'acceptons
pas que la réforme de la biologie
médicale soit renvoyée à des ordonnances
même si vous nous dites que ces
ordonnances seront ratifié par le
Parlement encore une fois ou bien ces
articles sont d're réglementaire et nous
ne devons pas perdre notre temps à les
examiner
ou bien on peut légiférer dessus et dans
ces conditions pourquoi n'en
discuterions-nous pas en profondeur
maintenant au lieu de nous contenter de
les ratifier
ensite voilà en quelques mots madame la
ministre ce que je souhaitais dire sur
ces articles bien sûr nous
interviendrons ensuite au au fil des
amendements collègue pas d'autres
demande monsieur
tin
monsieur le Président Madame la ministre
mes chers collègues je vis dire en quoi
nous sommes opposés à ce
recours aux
ordonnances sur une question de principe
mon collègue ficher vient de le dire
mais aussi nous sommes opposé au contenu
même de l'ordonnance que vos services
d'ailleurs ont bien voulu nous
communiquer qu'ils en soient remerciés
car
malgré
pardon alors
j'associe j'associe je vous associe
enfin oui ces remerciements s'adressent
aussi à vous madame la ministre fait pas
trop quand même c'est à sa demande je
peux pas quand
même car malgré un discours apparemment
rassurant quoique ce soir un peu
un peu tendu hein quant aux inquiétudes
qui sont celles des des biologistes nous
sommes contraints de constater que ce
qui se perd dans les faits c'est
l'application des dogmes
libéraux à cette profession ainsi je
souhaiterais vous renvoyer au contenu
même de cette ordonnance qui prévoit je
cite qu'un laboratoire médical est une
structure constituée d'un ou plusieurs
sites au sein de laquelle sont effectués
les éléments de biologie médicale fin de
citation cette rédaction madame la
ministre est alarmante en effet elle
témoigne de votre volonté de procéder à
la création de regroupement des centres
d'analyse dans de véritables
superstructures transformant les centres
de proximité en de simples établissement
de prélèvement le cœur de l'analyse
étant en réalité réalisé loin des
patients cette inquiétude nous l'avons
tant pour les quelques c000
professionnels concernés que pour les
patients qui voient s'éloigner un peu
plus un acteur supplémenta
des mission de service public
alors les propos que vous venez de tenir
concernant l'ouverture du capital par la
gauche font que nous sommes rassurés
hein en ce qui concerne une prochaine
ouverture par par vous-même he des
capitaux nous auriions pu le crânre mais
après les déclarations que vous venez de
tenir il est évident que on ne peut pas
non exactement on ne peut pas pas donc
on doit pas craindre de votre part une
nouvelle ouverture des capitaux dans les
années qui viennent hein donc écoutez
cette cette cette information nous
rassure et et et d'autant plus hein que
la le projet d'ordonnance que vous nous
avez confié est totalement mué sur ce
point et ne précise pas quant à la part
minimum de capital détenu par le
biologiste responsable alors autant la
l'ordonnance pouvait
nourrir chez nous quelques inquiétudes
autant vos déclarations sont rassurantes
alors il y a peut-être une contradiction
mais enfin je m'en tiens à vos propos et
je vous fais confiance comme d'habitude
cette précision j'en conviens d'ut et
d'autres règlementaires je souhaiterais
toutefois que
vous nous confirmiez quand même
aujourd'hui que le partage actuellement
prévu dans le décret restera ce qu'il
est restera identique je vis également
vous dire que nous sommes inquiets à la
lecture des dispositions relative aux
accréditations en effet il s'agit de
soumettre les laboratoires de biologie
médicale à une nouvelle accréditation
délivrée par le COFRAC afin de
satisfaire les normes européennes cette
norme venant remplacer celle délivrée
actuellement par la Haute Autorité de
Santé la norme dite de bioalité qui
atteste de la qualité et de la sécurité
des centres de biologie français cette
question de l'accréditation qui fait
directement référence à une logique
européenne interroge ne serait- qu'en
raison des coûts directs et indirects
induits par cette certification et qui
pourrait avoir pour conséquence
d'entraîner la fermeture de certains
centre de biologique les plus fragiles
économiquement pourriez-vous nous dire
Madame la Ministre les raisons qui vous
conduisent à préconiser cette nouvelle
accréditation au détriment de celle qui
était délivrée par la Haute Autorité de
Santé enfin et pour conclure je
souhaiterais que vous nous précisiez si
vous entendez vous opposer aux exigences
de l'ouverture de capital des
laboratoires à des investisseurs non
biologistes notamment au regard de la
décision rendue il y a peu par la Cour
de justice européenne en ce qui concerne
le capital des pharmacies d'officine et
qui s'oppose à son ouverture à des non
pharmacien merci chers collègues pas
d'autrre demande d'explication de vote
madame la ministre vous voulez
oui je veux rassurer monsieur monsieur
Houtin
effectivement c'est peut-être un peu
cruel à rappeler mais le capital des
laboratoires d'analyse a été ouvert à
des des non biologiste par la gauche
suite à une rectification que nous avons
faite ensuite nous l'avons limité à 25 %
parce que l'ouverture que vous aviez
préconisé à l'époque était ilillimité
100 % du capital aurait pu être détenu
par des nom biologistes heureusement que
nous sommes là à nouveau pour évidemment
réparer un certain nombre d'airrances
euh à l'époque vous n'étiez pas les
défenseurs de la biologie médicale et
bien entendu cette limitation 25% nous
avons évidemment pas entièrement
récupéré vos bêtises à l'époque mais
enfin cette limitation à 25 % nous
allons bien sûr la garder et je veux
vous dire que c'est suite à
l'argumentaire en défense du
gouvernement devant les instances
européennes que nous n'avons nous avons
réussi à obtenir qu' n'y ait pas euh de
la même façon libéralisation du capital
des officines de pharmacie et c'est
grâce aux arguments que j'ai défendu
devant devant les instances devant les
instances européennes alors vous savez
là-dessus vraiment je crois
que ah oui oui non mais monsieur hatin
là je crois que les défenseurs les
défenseurs de la détention du capital
par les professionnels sont de ce côté
de l'hémicycle là il y a vraiment il
peut y avoir des moments où il y a des
doutes mais là-dessus il n'y en a aucun
alors je veux dire simplement un mot sur
les systèmes de qualité parce qu'il y a
une certaine confusion dans votre propos
où vous mettez la Haute Autorité de
santé à toutes les sauces dans des
systèmes dans lequels elleintervient
absolument pas les systèmes de qualité
actuellement obligatoire pour les
laboratoires de biologie médicale c'est
le guide de bonne exécution des analyses
le GBEA qui est un référentiel qualité
obligatoire pour l'ensemble des
laboratoires publics et
privés bon il était novateur il a 15 ans
il est nettement moins maintenant et il
ne garantit absolument pas une qualité
suffisante et ne prévoit pas de modalité
de surveillance externe autre que
l'inspection le GBEA est déclaratif et
un laboratoire est inspecté tous les 15
à 40 ans et il ne peut plus constituer
ce GBEA un système de preuve de la
qualité le contrôle national de qualité
effectué par l'apsaps est une procédure
d'envoie d'échantillon biologique au
laboratoire pour dosage et également
novateur en son temps il est utile mais
insuffisant en terme de contrôle externe
de la qualité et les autres systèmes de
suivi de la qualité la certification les
systèmes d'assurance qualité sont
vérifiés par des organismes
certificateurs mais les les parties
techniques ne sont pas contrôlé donc la
certification qui est actuellement en en
action n'est pas reconnu
internationalement et ne permet pas un
monitoring permanent de la qualité
prouvé il y a également biocalité qui
est une association de professionnels
cré en 2002 qui prépare à
l'accréditation c'est une démarche
intéressante et qui constitue un soutien
méthodologique vers l'accréditation donc
véritablement nous avons un système qui
a été sans doute intéressant il y a une
vingtaine d'années qui n'est pas
suffisant qui n'est plus suffisant
d'ailleurs l'ensemble de la la mission
qui a été menée par Michel ballerau qui
est là l'a bien démontré avec les
professionnels c'est en cela que nous
vous proposons un système qui met
véritablement la qualité de la biologie
médicale au premier rang de du but que
nous poursuivons avec un maillage
territorial de
qualité merci Madame le
Ministre alors nous allons voter sur cet
amendement 510 que ceux qui souhaitent
l'adopter veuillent bien lever la main
merci que ceux qui sont contre veilleent
bien lever la main l'amendement n'est
pas
adopté
deux amendements font l'objet d'une
discussion commune l'amendement
763 il est présenté par Monsieur
Leen merci monsieur le Président Madame
la Ministre la biologie médicale
française est depuis toujours à la
pointe de la qualité les biologistes ont
mis au point le contrôle de qualité des
analyses dans les années 70 le guide de
bonne exécution des analyses existent
depuis
1994 et la profession a volontairement
mis en place biocalité un système
d'Assur qualité très élaboré de plus un
contrôle de qualité nationale
obligatoire vient compléter ce
dispositif déjà tout à fait satisfaisant
la biologie médicale est la plus avancée
en ce domaine de toutes les professions
de santé en France elle n'a rien à
envier à qui que ce soit l'immense
majorité des laboratoires de biologie
médicale fait actuellement une biologie
de qualité irréprochable unanimement
reconnu comme une des meilleures en
Europe les pouvoirs public ont les
moyens légaux de contrôler le respect de
cette qualité de sanctionner en cas de
faute c'est leur mission et il doivent
l'assurer cependant dans la continuité
des efforts déjà fournis depuis de
nombreuses années par la profession et
de manière à garantir et à améliorer la
qualité des examen il est utile que les
laboratoires de biologie médicale
continuent leur démarche pour autant
l'instauration d'un système d'assurance
qualité unique lié exclusivement à une
accréditation est extrêmement difficile
à mettre en place pour tous les
laboratoires de biologie médicale il
aboutit à des excès de procédurees
inutiles le plus souvent de nature
purement industrielle et peu adapté au
domaine médical par ailleurs une
accréditation n'apporte aucune garantie
supplémentaire quant à l'exactitude des
résultats des analyses médicales par
rapport à d'autres systèmes d'assurance
qualité de plus l'accréditation globale
des laboratoires de biologie médicale
est totalement inabordable
financièrement en coût direct et
indirect elle mettrait en très sérieuse
difficulté une grande partie des
laboratoires enfin le fait qu'un seul
organisme soit habilité à délivrer une
accréditation en France c'est le COFRAC
qui entend faire appliquer la norme
européenne 15189 place l'organisme dans
une situation de monopole qui apparaît
comme étant abusive l'accréditation doit
rester une démarche volontaire comme
partout en Europe une concurrence entre
les différents systèmes d'assurance
qualité actuellement à disposition des
laboratoires de biologie médicale et
saine source de progrès d'émulation
cette concurrence doit pouvoir s'exercer
pour des raisons financières évidentes
et de choix personnels dans la mesure où
le système d'assurance qualité choisi
par le laboratoire de biologie médicale
et bien sûr contrôlé par la Haute
Autorité de santé c'est pourquoi le
libre choix du système d'assurance
qualité est indispensable et s'impose je
vous rappelle d'ailleurs que c'est le
cas dans tous les autres pays européens
d'où notre amendement qui précise ces
points merci chers collègu l'amendement
184 il est présenté par Monsieur
Beaumont
oui merci monsieur le président madame
la
ministre permettez-moi tout d'abord en
préambule de souligner pour avoir
assisté à l'essentiel des débats de ce
texte depuis un certain temps maintenant
euh l'esprit de concertation préalable
d'information du Parlement de patience
dont a fait preuve notre ministre
et arrivant aujourd'hui à ce stade je
constate avec comme l'a fait avant moi
d'ailleurs le docteur Barbier qu'après
les médecins il y avait les dentistes et
qu'après les dentistes il y a maintenant
les
vétérinaires qui se et ceci totalement à
l'insu de leur pleing gré selon une
formule consacrée donc je voudrais
rappeler à Madame la Ministre très
cordialement comme j'ai toujours
l'habitude de le faire en ce qui la
concerne en particulier que je n'ai
jamais connu de concertation
d'information précise sauf une
convocation du président de l'Ordre pour
lui annoncer voilà ce qui se passait
alors j'avoue que j'ai été tenté tout à
l'heure de voter quelques amendements
qui disaient qu'on ne réforme pas la
biologie médicale par par ordonnance
c'est un sujet trop grave trop important
concernant trop de profession médicales
pour le faire comme ça y compris par un
amendement gouvernemental
subreptissement glissé dans une
discussion de commission ça me semble
pas être une formule tout à fait très
saine de faire évoluer de faire évoluer
la biologie médicale qui à mes yeux ne
peut être qu'unique parce qu'il y a
qu'une biologie en a qu'une elle est
animale l'homme étant l'un des animaux
mot privilégié bien sûr et que donc
depuis toujours les vétérinaires les
pharmaciens et les médecins ont été
associés au laboratoire de biologie
médicale j'ai du mal à comprendre
aujourd'hui que du d'un seul coup pour
une
réforme suivant
euh une étude très précise
d'un conseiller de Madame le Ministre
que je me trouve bien connaître et que
j'apprécie beaucoup par ailleurs mais
euh il a jamais été écrit que dans seul
coup fallait évincer systématiquement
les vétérinaires du système moi je vais
vous dire que la médecine humaine et la
médecine vétérinaire ont toujours
jusqu'à présent fait très bon ménage je
vais prendre des exemples à travers les
âges les âges les plus récents quand
même sans remonter trop loin mais tout
le monde se souvient que on a inventé au
l'époque de la tuberculose un vaccin
célèbre le BCG B c'est un ber de calmett
et merci Guérin c'est qui un vétérinaire
et oui et oui faut y penser
euh plus
récemment j' j'en ai un souvenir précis
parce que j'étais étudiant à l'École
vétérinaire à l'époque on a évoqué et on
a recherché les les systèmes
d'intervention sur le cerveau humain on
a commencé naturellement chez les
animaux et on a fait la
stéréotoxie la stéréotoxite du cerveau
chez les animau d'abord et on l'a
transposé chez le chien ça s'est passé à
la Faculté médecine de Lyon j'en ai
quelques souvenirs émus il y a quelques
années quelques longues années déjà
merci plus récemment plus récemment
l'encéphalo l'encéphalopathis
pongiformme bvine ah oui c'est une c'est
la maladie de la vache folle mais c'est
aussi la maladie de crisf
Jacob pourquoi est-ce qu'il y a
aujourd'hui en France que 42 morts de la
42 victimes de la maladie CR Jacob alors
qu'il y en a qui quelques centaines de
quelques centaines en Angleterre tout
simplement parce qu'on a un service
vétérinaire qui a coopéré très
précisément avec l'ensemble des services
de protection sanitaire et en
particulier les services médicaux pour
faire en sorte que c'est la propagation
de cette épidémie ne se répande pas sur
l'ensemble du
pays si aujourd'hui on veut
séparer la biologie médicale humaine de
la biologie médicale vétérinaire on fait
une grosse faute un moment tout à
fait tout à fait important en fait de
l'évolution justement des risques
sanitaires le risque sanitaire
aujourd'hui il est toujours
systématiquement par des
oonoses pour les non initiés
c'est-à-dire des maladies
qui viennent sont portés à la fois par
les animaux et par l'homme ils sont
souvent transmis par les animaux à
l'homme et on se trouve tout à fait
aujourd'hui dans un dans
l'actualité on est on y était il y a pas
longtemps avec les canards et le le
virus de l' l'h5 et ne on y est
aujourd'hui avec les cochons avec le le
virus H1 N1 on voit bien que le
vétérinaire et que le monde animal est
présent partout et qu'en fait la
biologie toute cette démonstration est
faite pour montrer que la biologie elle
est elle est unique elle ne peut pas se
diviser j'ajoute en fait que j'ajoute
ensuite que bien
évidemment si on supprime si on interdit
au vétérinaire d'accéder à ce diplôme on
les prive d'abord d'une potentialité
importante d'un diplôme difficile
aujourd'hui obtenu après au minimum 8
années d'études c'estàdire quelque chose
d'assz conséquent me semble-t-il et que
en
plus on on va avoir bien du mal à
trouver des vétérinaires biologistes
pour assurer une autre mission
qui apparaît évidente aujourd'hui pour
les vétérinaires et qu'il a toujours été
pour eux et qui et qu' ont assumé avec
beaucoup de succès je crois pouvoir dire
en France c'est tout le contrôle
sanitaire des aliments des aliments
d'origine animale et consommé par
l'homme ce sont bien les vétérinaires
qui les contrôlent ils ont besoin de
formation cette formation si on les
prive de cette formation ils seront
absolument absolument incapable dans
quelques années de pouvoir l'assumer
alors si vous me dites madame la
ministre que c'est bien pour ça que vous
avez décidé par ordonnance cette cette
mesure pour priver les les vétérinaires
désormais du contrôle des animaux des
denrées alimentaires d'origine animale
et et confier ça au médecins ou au
pharmaciens alors là je vous comprendrai
volontiers je serai naturellement encore
beaucoup plus contre vous je sais bien
que c'est pas pour ça mais si c'est pas
pour ça c'est que vous avez besoin des
vétérinaires et conservez-les il y a que
ça à faire nous avons aujourd'hui de
nombreux vétérinaires de nombreux
laboratoires d'analysees d'analyse
biie médicale je termine monsieur le
Président merci de nombreux laboratoires
de d'analyse de biologie médicale qui
sont spécialisés dans une branche de
leur activité sur justement ce contrôle
des aliments et ils ont raison ils
auront besoin des vétérinaires pourquoi
voulez-vous priver ces pauvres
vétérinaires de cette formation ça me
semble aujourd'hui vraiment une ouase
qui est tombée comme ça d'un seul coup
sur les vétérinaires qui ne demandaient
rien et qui avait jusqu'à présent assuré
parfaitement leur mission je
souhaiterais que vous que pour l'instant
on puisse surceoir à cette décision et
qu'on puisse avoir une vraie discussion
dans le monde vétérinaire avec vous
Madame la Ministre pour faire en sorte
qu'on trouve une solution équitable
celle-elà ne l'est pas merci chers
collègu monsieur le rapporteur l'avis de
la
commission monsieur le Président merci
d'abord l'amendement 763 du groupe
socialiste je voudrais rappeler que
l'article l62 21-1 du projet
d'ordonnance prévoit un système
d'accréditation sous les gites de la
Haute Autorité de santé et que l'article
62 21-2 des contrôles extérieurs sur
lesgide de la saaps ce dispositif est
suffisant il garantit la qualité des
examens de biologie médicale et par
ailleurs les professionnels peuvent
recourir à l'assurance de leur choix
c'est donc un avis défavorable à
l'amendement pour ce qui est de de
l'amendement de notre collègue Beaumont
je veux dire mon mon cher collègue que
je vais essayer d'avoir un peu moins de
pati j'en ai d'ailleurs un peu moins que
vous pour présenter l'avis de la
commission qui va pas être facile à vous
présenter mais cet amendement propose en
fait vous l'avez bien dit de maintenir
la possibilité pour les vétérinaires de
se spécialiser en biologie médicale il
est vrai qu'interdire cette
spécialisation revient à se priver d'un
apport de compéten utile surtout à une
époque où de nombreux virus risquent de
se de se transmettre de l'animal à
l'homme et vous avez fait allusion à
quelques maladies célèbres
mais les vétérinaires ne sont pas
reconnus comme une profession médicale
ce qui pour la Commission européenne
implique s'ils peuvent avoir la
responsabilité d'un laboratoire de
biologie médicale que celle-ci est une
simple prestation de service si j'ai
bien compris ce qu'on m'a expliqué il
faut reconnaître que la possibilité de
spécialisation des vétérinaires reste
une spécification et une spécificité
purement française c'est pour permettre
le succès de la réforme au regard du
droit communautaire que la Commission
d'affaires sociales donc vous demandera
un retrait sinon sera obligé d'émettre
un avis défavorable ce qui fait un ce
qui fera pe mal au ventre s réserve
évidemment d'un avis du gouvernement
merci monsieur le rapporteur madame la
ministre l'avis du
Gouvernement
bien j'ai trouvé assez curieux
l'argumentation qui voudrait qu'on
libéralise en quelque sorte les
organismes
d'accréditation parce que si on vous
suit monsieur leemain qui va accréditer
les organismes
accréditeurs si on laisse se développer
une espèce de foire aux organismes
d'accréditation il est bien évident que
par définition une procédure
d'accréditation fait appel à un
organisme public indépendant et qui
garantit cette accréditation là vraiment
dans le domaine de la biologie médicale
vous jouez absolument à front renversé
sur la qualité que qu'on exige après
avoir vanté les mérites de la
libéralisation du capital des
laboratoires d'analyse voilà maintenant
vous ventez les la libéralis tion des
des mécanismes d'accréditation alors là
franchement je je je ne vous comprends
plus et et
véritablement bien sûr le rôle de la
Haute Autorité de Santé est essentiel
dans dans la dans le système d'assurance
qualité des laboratoires la mise en
œuvre de l'accréditation se fera en lien
étroit avec cette Haute Autorité de
Santé la Haute Autorité de santé sera au
côté du cofrc c'est-à-dire l'organisme
public chargé de l'accréditation pour
veiller avec la cohérence des procédures
la cohérence avec la politique nationale
la politique de santé et elle sera
également au côté du COFRAC pour
l'élaboration du manuel d'accréditation
qu'on appelle encore le document
d'exigence spécifique pour
l'accréditation des laboratoire de
biologie médicale évidemment on ne peut
pas imaginer un autre processus
d'accréditation qu'un procéd qu'un
processus d'accréditation sous j'allais
dire sous l'emprise de la pu publique
c'est pas vous monsieur le main qui
allez défendre autre chose je suis
résolument contre votre contre votre
amendement alors je je voudrais
maintenant répondre à à à René baaumont
euh le le projet de de réforme je l'ai
dit c'est un processus de médicalisation
de la biologie médicale le je voudrais
donner une peut-être pendant une minute
une explication un peu plus fouillée le
biologiste médical est évidemment
responsable de la qualité de toutes les
étapes de l'examen du prélèvement
jusqu'au cont-rendu du résultat validé
et interprété en fonction des éléments
pertinents que le clinicien aura
communiqué au biologiste c'est pas un
professionnel de santé qui est hors sol
c'est quelqu'un qui a un vrai contact
avec le malade qui lui parle qui parle
de sa maladie qui fait partie d'une
équipe soignante et c'est justement
peut-être ça qui a manqué à la biologie
médicale c'est c'est de ne pas être
incluse dans un processus de
professionnel de santé et bien
évidemment à partir du moment où je veux
remédicaliser la biologie médicale je je
ne peux pas la confier à quelqu'un qui
n'est dont je ne mets pas en cause c'est
les compétences
bien
a prise en charge de patients humains
alors la formation des vétérinaires est
de très haut niveau loin de moi de faire
une hiérarchie en disant les uns sont
supérieurs aux autres ou inférieurs mais
elle est axée évidemment sur la prise en
charge d'une diversité importante
d'espèce animal à l'exception de l'homme
il n'y a rien dans les études
vétérinaires qui qui font la la
connaissance de l'homme et elle n'est
pas cette formation de nature à remplir
cet objectif il il ne s'agit pas le
rapporteur l'a dit d'une profession de
santé au code de la santé publique la
vocation d'un vétérinaire n'est pas de
prendre en humain même si au niveau de
la recherche il peut y avoir des
croisements et vous les avez très
justement soulignés même si des
recherches en en médecine vétérinaire
peuvent évidemment avoir des des
implications et des applications en
médecine humaine la vocation d'un
médecin d'un pharmacien n'est pas de
prendre en charge les animaux vocation
d'un vétérinaire n pas de prendre en
charge des hommes et si la compétence en
biologie médicale est essentielle en
biologie médicale humaine elle doit être
associée à cette compétence en médecine
humaine ou en pharmacie alors le le
c'est un j'allais dire c'est un argument
que le rapporteur a utilisé mais
j'allais dire c'est pas le fond du
problème c'est vrai que si nous
autorisons dans le cadre de la réforme
de la biologie les vétérinaires à exercé
la profession de la biologie médicale
nous nous fragilisons beaucoup parce que
nous appliquerons à ce moment-là les
instances européennes diront qu'il
s'agit pas d'une profession de santé
mais d'une prestation de service et nous
appliquerons la directive d'bolkestin
nous voulons l'éviter donc nous
fragilisons notre argumentation
juridique donc il paraît donc nécessaire
dans le cas d'une biologie médicale
centrée sur le patient humain de mettre
fin des procédures dérogatoires qui sont
d'ailleurs très limitées donnons au
vétérinaires diplômés
un accès au titre de biologiste médical
bien entendu je veux vous rassurer les
vétérinaires exerçant actuellement les
fonctions de directeur ou de directeur
adjoint de laboratoire pourront
poursuivre leur fonction de biologiste
médical il n'y a donc pas de de mise en
en danger de ces professionnels je veux
vous rassurer il en sera de même pour
ceux qui sont entrés effectivement en
spécialisation biologie médicale avant
la date de promulgation du texte portant
la réforme donc il y a pas de mesure
rétroactive dans ce domaine premier
élément pour vous rassurer deuxème
élément ce n'est pas l'accès à la
formation du diplôme d'études spécialisé
de biologie médicale qui est fermé au
vétérinaire c'est la possibilité pour
les vétérinaires d'avoir le titre de
biologiste médical humain c'est c'est
bien le moins hein ils pourront
travailler en laboratoire de de biologie
vétérinaire comme par exemple les labor
départementaux ou en laboratoire de
biologie médicale humaine mais ils ne
pourront pas dans ce cas valider
interpréter et signer des résultats
d'examen de biologie médicale humaine
parce que la biologie médicale humaine
c'est une profession médicale c'est une
profession de santé et la profession de
vétérinaire n'a pas cette qualification
en outre et je veux le redire le rôle
très important que vous jouez dans la
recherche n'est absolument pas remise en
cause donc au motif de ces de ces
explications de cette pldoirie euh je
vous serais très très reconnaissante si
vous pouviez retirer votre
amendement merci Madame la
Ministre alors sur le
763 pas d'explication de vote que ceux
qui souhaitent adopter cet amendement
veuille bien lever la
main merci que ceux qui sont contre
veuillent bien lever la main
l'amendement n'est pas adopté sur le 184
est-il retiré
explication de vote monsieur beaumon
oui monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre j'ai bien écouté avec beaucoup
beaucoup d'attention vous en doutez vos
arguments j'ai vu un progrès évident qui
que j'avais cité que j'avais souhaité
c'est que l'accès au des sera bien
maintenu au
vétérinaire il y en a un vrai besoin
parce qu'il y a besoin d'équipe
pluraliste en matière de nous
interrompons la séance pour prendre tout
de suite la direction du ypte président
américain bar Obama va prononcer un
discours très attendu sur une nouvelle
donne entre l'Amérique et le monde musul
il devrait délivrer un message fort de
réconciliation pour tourner la page
deouche on écoute bar
Obama
merci merci infiniment bonjour à
tous c'est un honneur pour moi de me
retrouver dans la ville éternelle
du et d'être accueilli par deux
institutions
remarquables pendant plus de 1000
ans Lazar a été au cœur du monde
islamique et launiversité du
été iration ensemble il représente une
harmonie entre l'inspiration et le
progrès je suis reconnaissant pour votre
hospitalité et l'hospitalité du peuple
égyptien et je suis également fier
d'apporter la bonne volonté du peuple
américain et un message de paix des
communautés musulmanes de mon P pays
salam
alkoum
nous nous
retrouvons en des temps de tension
importantes entre les États-Unis et les
musulmans du monde entier les tensions
qui VO leur sources dans
des rais historique la relation entre
l'Islam et
l'Occident
amabق عل الكثير منلمين ينظونى الغرب انها
معاد لتقالي
الالامغلunfتat bah
shديثlin هج الح من سبtم am
2001ستمr jه
هؤلاءشد في الانخراط في العنف
ضددنيين جعل البعض في بلده ينظر الى
الاسلام
nous vous prions de vous excuser nous
avons quelques problèmes de traduction
tout de suite vous allez pouvoir suivre
la suite du discours de Barack Obama en
direct de l'Université du K et cette
fois-ci le discours sera traduit en
français par nos
différences
et nous
insisterons pour lutter contre ceux qui
font la promotion du conflit et non pas
ceux qui recherch la paix et la
prospérité dans ce cycle de suspition et
de discorde et bien ce cycle doit
prendre fin je suis venu ici au C
pour commencer un nouveau chemin entre
les États-Unis et le monde musulman un
chemin qui soit fondé sur des intérêts
mutuel et le respect mutuel un chemin
qui soit fondé sur la volonté la
conviction
que les États-Unis et le monde musulman
ne sont pas exclusif l'un de l'autre
mais au contraire partage des principes
commun des principes de justice de
progrès de
tolérance et de dignité de l'ensemble
des êtres
humains je faisais je fais en
reconnaissant que le changement ne
pourra pas intervenir du jour au
lendemain alors a beaucoup parl de mon
discours mais un discours ne peut pas
éradiquer des années de
méfiance
pas plus que dans le temps qui m'est
imparti cet après-midi je ne sauris
répondre à l'ensemble des questions
complexes sur le sujet mais je suis
convaincu que pour
avancer nous devons dire ouvertement les
uns aux autres les choses que nous avons
sur le cœur choses qui bien souvent ne
sont dites que derrière des portes
closes nous devons entreprendre un
effort soutenu pour nous écouter les un
des les uns des autres pour nous
apprendre un des autres pour nous
respecter mutuellement et pour trouver
des points de
convergence comme le Coran nous le dit
soyons conscient de Dieu et disons
toujours la
vérité et c'est exactement ce que
j'essai de faire aujourd'hui de dire la
vérité
possible humble face à la tâche qui nous
attend et ferme dans ma conviction que
l'intérêt que nous partageons en tant
qu'être humain est bien supérieur aux
forces qui nous
séparent cette
conviction je la tiens de ma propre
expérience en partie je suis chrétien
mais mon père venait d'une famille kan
et des génération de
musulmans j'ai passé des années de mon
enfance Indonésie et j'ai entendu
l'appel du Azan à l'aube et au
crépuscule et en tant que jeune j'ai
travaillé dans des communautés à Chicago
où beaucoup ont trouvé la dignité et la
paix dans leur foi
musulmane je connais par que j'ai étudié
l'histoire la dette de la civilisation
envers l'Islam c'est l'islam
qui dans des lieux comme
Alazar ont transmis le savoir pendant
des siècles et des siècles apportant la
lumière et la Renaissance à l'Europe
c'est la la rénovation des communautés
musulmanes l'innovation des communautés
musulmanes qui ont développé
l'algèbre la Bousso ou les instruments
de navigation
l'imprimerie
qui ont compris comment les maladies se
propagai comment pourra P être soigné
l'islam nous a donc inspiré nous a
beaucoup
apporter la musique la
calligraphie et des endroits de
contemplation pacifique et à travers
l'histoire l'Islam a démontré par les
faits et par les mots les possibilités
de tolérance religieuse et d'égalité
raciale
je sais aussi que
l'islam toujours fait partie de
l'histoire
américaine la première nation à
reconnaître mon pays a été le
Maroc en signant le traité de Tripoli en
1796 notre deè
président écrit que les États-Unis n' en
so
aucune animosité contre les lois la
religion la tranquillité des musulmans
et depuis notre fondation les les
musulmans américains ont enrichi les
États-Unis ils ont lutté dans nos
guerres ils ont servi dans nos
gouvernements ils sont battus pour les
droits CIVIS ils ont lancé des
entreprises ils ont enseigné et et
appris dans nos universités ils ont fait
du sport dans nos stade ils ont
construit et ils ont même porté la
torche
olympique et
lorsque le premier musulman américain a
été élu au Congrès il a prêté srement
notre Constitution sur le même Coran que
Thomas Jefferson des pèr fondateur avait
dans sa bibliothèque
personnelle je connais
l'islam avant de venir région où il est
apparu et cette expérience guide ma
conviction selon laquelle le partenariat
entre l'Amérique et l'islam doit se
fonder sur ce qu l'islam et non pas sur
ce qu'il n'est
pas et je considère comme une de mes
responsabilités en tant que président
des États-Unis de lutter contre les
stéréotypes négatifs de l'islam là où
ils
sont
mais ce même principe doit s'appliquer
également aux perceptions musulmanes de
l'Amérique de la même
manière que les musulmans ne répondent
pas à un stéréotype unique l'Amérique
n'est pas un stéréotype d' d'un empire
uniement intéressé par soi-même les
États-Unis ont été l'une des sources de
progrès les plus importantes que le
monde a jamais connu nous sommes nés
d'une révolution contre un
empire nous avons fondé notre pays sur
l'idée que tous sont égau et nous avons
lutté par notre sang pendant des siècles
pour donner du sens à ces
mots dans nos frontières et à
l'extérieur dans le monde
entier nous sommes façonnés par
cult venant du monde entier et orienté
vers un concept
unique de beaucoup un
seul et je suis un exemple
unaméricain appel Barack husin Obama
peut être élu président des
États-Unis mais mon histoire personnelle
n'est pas si
unique le rêve de d'opportunité pour
tous n'est pas vrai pour tous en
Amérique mais cette promesse existe pour
tous ceux qui viennent ce qui
implique près de 7 millions de musulmans
américains qui dans notre pays
aujourd'hui de
fait gagne davantage que la moyenne
américaine
de
plus la liberté en Amérique est
indivisible de la liberté de
culte c'est pour
cela y a des mosquées dans chacun de nos
états protégeons par exemple le droit
des filles et des femmes à porter le
voil et nous punissons ce qui renit ce
droit donc il ne fait aucun
doute l'islam fait partie de
l'Amérique et je suis convaincu que
l'Amérique en son
sein partage cette idée que tous
indépendamment de leur religion ou de
leur
race visent les mêmes objectifs la paix
la sécurité un travail une éducation la
possibilité d'aimer leur famille leur
communauté leur Dieu voilà autant
d'éléments que nous partageons et c'est
là l'espoir de l'ensemble de
l'humanité bien sûr reconnaître notre
humanité commune n'est que le début de
notre travail les
mots seul ne peuvent pas répondre aux
besoins des peuples ces
besoins ne seront répondus que si nous
travaillons efficacement dans les années
à venir et si nous comprenons que nos
défis sont conjoints et si nous
répondons pas à ces défis nous en
souffrirons tous nous avons appris des
expériences récentes que lorsqu'un
système financier s'affaiblit dans un
pays la prospérité en souffre
partout lorsqu'une nouvelle un nouveau
virus de la
grippe touche un être humain c'est
l'ensemble des êtres humains qui sont en
danger lorsqu'une nation se dote de
l'arme nucléaire le risque d'attaque
nucléaire plane sur
tous lorsque les terroristes réfugient
dans des montagnes c'est le monde entier
qui sont en qui est en
danger voilà ce que veut dire partager
le monde dans ce 21e siècle c'est là la
responsabilité que nous avons les uns
envers les autres en tant qu'êtres
humain et c'est une responsabilité
difficile à
assumer car l'histoire de
l'humanité regorge d'exemples de nation
de tribus et oui de religion également
qui se subjug les unes les
autres dans la quête de leur propr
intérêt
ces types d'attitude sont voué à
l'échec étant donné notre
interdépendance chaque P du monde qui
érie un peuple audessus d'un autre
échouera
inévitablement nous devons tirer les
leçons du passé sans en être
prisonniers nous avons appris à être des
partenaires prrs tre
partagé ceci ne veut pas dire que nous
devons
ignorer les éléments de tension et de
fait ça veut plutôt dire l'inverse nous
devons faire
face frontalement à ces tension et dans
cet esprit permettez-moi d'être aussi
clair et explicite que possible sur un
point spécifique dont je crois nous
devrons aborder et nous et attaquer
ensemble premier
point l'extrémisme violent sous toutes
ses
formes j'ai dit clairement à Ankara que
l'Amérique ne serait jamais en guerre
avec
l'islam et pourtant
nous lutterons sans cesse contre
l'extrémisme violent qui représente une
menace importante contre notre contre
nos peuples car tout le monde rejette
l'assassinat d'innocent de femmes et
d'hommes et d'enfants innocents et mon
premier devoir en tant que Président
c'est de protéger le peuple
américain la situation en Afghanistan
démre les
objectifs de l'Amérique et notre de
travailler
ensemble il y a 7 ans les États-Unis ont
poursuivi
Al-Qaïda et les talibans avec l'aide de
la communauté internationale nous n'y
sommes pas allés par choix nous y sommes
allés par besoin par nécessité et je
suis conscient qu'il reste encore des
gens pour se poser la question voir même
justifier le 11 septembre mais soyons
clair al-Qaïda a tué près de 3000
personnes ce jour-là
les victimes étaient des hommes des
femmes et des enfants innocents
d'Amérique mais aussi d'autres nations
qui n'avaient rien fait qui n'avait nuit
à
personne et pourtant al-Qaïda a choisi
d'assassiner ces
gens-là revendiquant l'attaque
et revendiquant même aujourd'hui leur
détermination à tuer à grande
échelle ce ne sont pas des opinions qui
peuvent se débattre ce sont des faits
que nous devons
traiter et ne nous trompons pas nous ne
voulons pas maintenir nos troupes en
Afghanistan nous n'envisageons pas une
implantation militaire durable là-bas
mais nous voulons protéger les
Américains et c'est difficile c'est
coûteux politiquement et financièrement
de poursuivre ce conflit et nous serions
ravi de pouvoir ramener toutes nos
troupes à la maison si nous pouvions
être sûr qu'il n'y ait pas de
d'extrémistes violent en Afghanistan et
désormais au Pakistan déterminé à tuer
autant d'Américains qu'ils
peuvent ce n'est pas encore le
cas et c'est pour ça que nous
travaillons avec une coalition de 46
pays et malgré le coup l'engagement
américain ne faiblira pas car personne
aucun d'entre nous ne devrait tolérer
ces extrémistes ils ont tué dans bien
des pays ils ont tué des gens de
différentes confession mais par-dessus
tout ils ont tué des
musulmans leurs actions sont
inconciliables avec le droit des êtres
humains les progrès des nations et
l'islam lui-même le Coran nous apprend
que quiconque tue un
innocent et l'équivalent d'avoir tué
l'ensemble de l'humanité
et le Coran dit également que
quiconque sauve une
personne fait comme s'il avait sauvé
l'ensemble de
l'humanité la foi de plus d'un milliard
de personnes est tellement plus grande
que la haine étroite d'une
poignée l'islam n'est pas une partie du
problème de la lutte contre l'extrémisme
non c'est une partie importante de la
solution pour lutter contre extrémistes
et nous savons bien entendu que les les
aspects militaires ne résoudront pas
tous les problèmes en Irak en
Afghanistan et c'est pour cela que nous
allons 1,5 milliard de dollar chaque
année pendant les C premères années
prochaines années pour construire des
écoles en Afghanistan et pour aider tous
ceux qui ont été déplacés c'est pour
cela que nous donnons plus de 2,8
milliards de dollars pour aider les
Afghans à développer leur
économie et apporter des services sur
lesquels les gens dépendent et
permettez-moi également de revenir sur
la question de
l'Irak à l'inverse de
l'Afghanistan l'Irak a fait l'objet d'un
choix défendu fermement dans mon pays et
dans le monde entier et même si je crois
que le peuple
iraakien est mieux LTI sans la tyranie
de Saddam Hussein je crois également que
les événements iraquiens ont rappelé
l'Amérique à l'Amérique le besoin
d'utiliser la diplomatie et le consensus
pour résoudres problèmes lorsque cela
est
possible
rappelons-nous les mots de Thomas
Jefferson qui a dit j'espère que notre
sagesse va grandir en même temps que
notre pouvoir moins nous utilisons la
force plus importante elle sera
aujourd'hui l'Amérique a une double
responsabilité d'aider l'Irak à forger
un avenir meilleur et de redonner l'IRAC
aux iraakiens j'ai dit très clairement
au peuple iraakien
j'ai dit très clairement au peuple
iraakien que nous ne cherchons pas à
nous installer que nous n'avons aucune
prétention concernant
l'Irak l'Irak est un pays
souverain c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai demandé que certaines de nos
brigades s'en aill d'Irak dès le mois
d'août nous allons tenir notre
engagement les troupes dans les villes
iriennes partiront d'ici Ju etes les
trpes seront par en
2012 nous allons aider l'Irak à former
ses forces de sécurité et à développer
son économie mais nous voulons que
l'Irak soit un partenaire et nous ne
voulons pas regarder l'IRAC de
haut nous pvons pasér la violence des
extrémistes mais nous ne pouvons
pas également oublier nos principes le
11 septembre suppose un traumatisme
terrible pour notre pays la peur
l'angoisse que cela a créé son tout à
fait compréhensible mais parfois cela
nous a amené à aller à l'encontre de nos
traditions et de nos
idéaux et maintenant nous prenons des
actions très concrètes pour nous
remettre sur le droitchemin je interdis
l'utilisation
des de la torture et je veux la
fermeture de la prison de Guantanamo
avant la fin de l'année prochaine
l'année
prochaine
l'Amérique bien sûr se
défendra en respectant la souveraineté
des nations et l'état de
droit
et nous le ferons en partenariat avec
les communautés musulmanes qui sont
menacé plus rapidement nous arriverons à
isoler les extrémistes et plus
rapidement nous serons tous en
sécurité la deuxème source majeure de
tension dont nous devons discuter est la
situation entre les Israéliens les
Palestiniens et le monde
arabe
les liens très forts entre l'Amérique et
Israël sont bien
connus ces liens ne seront jamais brisés
ils sont fondés sur des liens
historiques politiques et sur la
reconnaissance du
fait que le droit au peuple d'Israël de
disposer d'une
terre fait suite à une persécution
pendant des
l'antisémitisme en
Europe a provoqué un holocauste terrible
demain je me rendrai à bukenvald un camp
dans lequel les Juifs ont
été emprisonnés torturés gazé et tué par
le 3è Raich 6 millions de Juifs ont été
tués plus que la population israélienne
aujourd'hui niz cela c'est ridicule
c'est sans fondement
historique menacer Israël de destruction
répéter des
stéréotypes stupides et négatif sur les
Juifs ne sert à rien cela ne
fait qu'empêcher la paix à laquelle ont
droit les peuples de cette région
d'autre part il est également impossible
de nier que le peuple
palestinien composés de chrétiens et de
musulmans a souffer dans sa quête de
terre pendant plus de 60 ans les
Palestiniens ont souffert de leur
déplacement beaucoup qui vivent dans les
camps de réfugiés en S Jordanie ou à
Gaza à l'attente de la paix et de la
sécurité qu'ils n'ont jamais plus pu
atteindre ils vivent au quotidien
l'humiliation que suppose l'occupation
donc qu'il n'y ait aucun doute sur le
fait que la situation pour le peuple
palestinien est une situation
intolérable les États-Unis ne vont pas
tourner leur dos aux aspirations
naturelles et légitime du peuple
palestinien à obtenir une
terre
pendant des
décennies des peuples avec des
aspirations légitime chacun avec une
histoire difficile et
douloureuse ne sont pas parvenus au
compromis il est facile de pointer du
Doig de la part des Palestiniens pointer
du doigt la création de l'État d'Israël
et
ensuite de l'autre côté attaques qui
sont faites à Israël et au Juifs
ailleurs mais si l'on
regarde les choses que d'un seul côté
alors nous ne verrons jamais la vérité
la seule résolution c'est de prendre en
compte la situation des deux peuples
avec la création de deux États qui
puissent vivre en paix et en
sécurité
et cela est dans l'intérêt d'Israël dans
l'intérêt de la Palestine dans l'intérêt
des États-Unis d'Amérique dans l'intérêt
du monde entier et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je vais personnellement essayer
de faire avancer cet objectif avec toute
la patience et l'engagement que cette
tâche
implique les
obligations sur lesquell les deux par
sont mis d'accord la cette feuille de
route est claire pour parvenir à la paix
il est donc grand temps pour eux pour
nous
tous de
revenir et de voir quelles sont nos
responsabilités la résistance par la
violence et la tuerie n'amène nulle
part pendant des siècles les Noirs
américains ont souffert de l'humiliation
de la ségrégation des coups de fouet de
leurs maître
mais ce n'est pas en par la violence
qu'on a atteint les droits c'est par une
insistance permanente en rappelant
queles étaient les idéaux des
perfondateurs et cette histoire c'est
presque la
même qui est raconté en Afrique du Sud
en Asie du Sud-Est en Europe c'est la
même histoire avec une vérité simple la
violence ne mène nul part la violence
n'est pas un signe de n pas un signe de
force envoyer des bombes sur des enfants
faire sauter une femme dans un bus ce
n'est pas de cette manière qu'on réclame
l'autorité morale c'est de la
lâcheter il est grand temps pour les
Palestiniens de se concentrer sur ce
qu'ils peuvent construire l'Autorité
palestinienne doit renforcer sa capacité
de gouvernement en créant des
institutions qui soi au service de son
peuple le
Hamas bien sûr a l'appui de certains
Palestiniens mais il faut reconnaître
quelle est la responsabilité du Hamas
également jouer le rôle qui doit être le
sien d'unifier le peuple palestinien et
de répondre aux aspirations du peuple
palestinien le Hamas doit reconnaître
les accords passés reconnaître le droit
d'Israël à exister renoncer à la
violence et dans le même temps les
Israéliens doivent
reconnaître que tout comme
le droit d'Israël exist ne peut être nié
ce droit pour les Palestiniens ne peut
être nié non
plus nous devons en finir avec la
colonisation
israélienne ces constructions viole les
accords passés et empêche de parvenir à
la paix il est temps que cette
colonisation
Israël doit se souvenir ses obligations
et assurer que les Palestiniens peuvent
vivre travailler et
développer la société
palestinienne la crise humanitaire à
Gaza
empêche de parvenir à la sécurité en
Israël la même chose en S Jordanie les
problèmes quotidiens des Palestiniens
doivent être réglés et doivent être un
un des points essentiels de la paix et
Israël va devoir
prendre des mesures pour permettre de
progresser sur cette voie les États
arabes pour finir doivent reconnaître
que l'initiative de paix était un bon
début mais ce n pas la fin des
responsabilités le conflit israéloarabe
ne doit pas être
utilisé pour détourner l'attention des
peuples
arabes il faut absolument aider les
Palestiniens à développer leurs
institutions reconnaître la légitimité
d'Israël et essayer d'éviter les erreurs
du
passé
l'Amérique sera côte à côte avec ceux
qui souhaitent la paix et nous allons
dire en public ce que nous disons privé
que ce soit au Palestiniens aux
israéliens ou aux arabes en
général nous ne pouvons pas imposer la
paix
mais en privé beaucoup de musulmans
disent que Israël ne va pas disparaître
tout comme les Israéliens beaucoup
d'Israéliens disent qu'il faut un État
palestinien essayons
maintenant d'agir par rapport à la
vérité trop de larmes ont été versé trop
de sang à couler nous avons tous une
responsabilité travailler pour ce jour
où les mères palestiniennes et
israéliennes pourront voir leurs enfants
grandir sans père quand la Terre sainte
des trois
grandes religions monothéistes sera
enfin l'endroit que Dieu a voulu un
endroit de paix quand les chrétiens les
juifs
et les
musulmans pourront jouer ensemble comme
le dit l'histoire
d'isra qu'elle devienne enfin la terre
d'Abraham quand dans l'histoire d'isra
mahomé Moïse et Jésus pourront
enfin se joindre dans la même prière en
paix troisè source de tension
maintenant c'est notre intérêt partagé
concernant les responsabilités des
nations quant à l'utilisation de l'arme
nucléaire cette question est une source
de
tension entre les États-Unis d'Amérique
et la République islamique d'Iran
pendant beaucoup
d'années
l'Iran a vécu en opposition à mon
pays au milieu de la guerre
froide
les États-Unis ont renversé un
gouvernement élu de manière
démocratique l'Iran a
également agi contre les civils et les
troupes américaines nous avons tous not
tur mais plutôt que de rester les yeux
rivés sur le passé j'ai dit très
clairement au peuple iranien et au
leader iranien que nous étions prêts à
aller de l'avant la question est
maintenant n'est pas de savoir
ce contre quoi est l'Iran mais ce que
veut construire l'Iran je sais qu'il
sera très difficile d'en finir avec des
décennies de méfiance mais nous sommes
engagés à agir dignement et de manière
droite nous voulons aller de l'avant
sans préalable sur la base du respect
mutuel mais il est clair pour tous que
quand il s'agit d'armes nucléaires nous
avons atteint un point décisif il ne
s'agit pas uniquement de l'intérêt des
États-Unis d'Amérique c'est pour éviter
une course à l'armement nucléaire au
Moyen-Orient qui pourrait mener mener
cette région et le monde entier sur un
chemin beaucoup trop dangereux je
comprends ceux qui protestent et qui
disent que certains disposent de ces
armes et d'autres pas aucune nation
seule devrait choisir qui doit avoir
l'arme nucléaire c'est la raison pour
laquelle je répète que nous voulons une
planète sans armes nucléaires qu'aucune
nation ne dispose de l'arme
nucléaire et aucune nation et toutes
toutes les nations même l'Iran peuvent
avoir accès au nucléaire civil si ces
pays signent le traité de non
prolifération nucléaire
c'est un élément essentiel le nucléaire
civil au sein de ce traité et je suis
convaincu que nous partageons cet
objectif tous dans la région 4è point la
démocratie je sais qu'il y a eu beaucoup
de controversse concernant la promotion
de la démocratie et cette controverse
est liée à la guerre en irac en irac je
va être clair aucun système de
gouvernement ne devrait être imposé par
une nation sur une
autre
cela ne réduit pas mon
engagement je veux des gouvernements qui
reflètent la volonté du
peuple chaque pays
ESS de faire cela en prenant en compte
sa culture nous prétention de savoir ce
qui est bon pour
tous comme nous ne pouvons pas prédire
les résultats d'une élection pacifique
mais j'ai néanmoins une croyance très
enracinée sur le fait que le peuple doit
avoir la possibilité de dire ce qu'il
pense sur la manière dont il est
gouverné confiance en l'état de droit
une égalité de traitement par la justice
disposer d'un gouvernement transparent
qui ne vole pas son peuple la liberté de
vivre comme on l'entend ce ne sont pas
des idéaux américains ce sont des droits
de l'homme c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous allons les appuyer
partout pour tenir cette promesse il n'y
a
pas de plan tout fait mais les
gouvernements qui protègent ces
droits sont plus sûr plus prospère
essayer de supprimer des idées ça ne les
fait pas
disparaître l'Amérique
respecte le droit de toutes les voix
pacifiques qui veulent se faire entendre
dans le monde même quand nous ne sommes
pas d'accord avec elle et nous allons
saluer tous les gouvernements élus de
manière pacifique si ils gouvernent
pacifiquement et prennent en compte tout
leur population c'est un élément
important car beaucoup en appelle à la
démocratie quand ils n'en sont pas au
pouvoir mais quand ils sont au pouvoir
ils essaient de supprimer le droit
d'autres il faut un gouvernement par le
peuple et pour le
peuple ça devrait être la norme pour
ceux qui ont le pouvoir il faut
maintenir se maintenir au pouvoir par le
biais du consensus et pas de la menace
il faut respecter les droits des
minorités et participer dans un esprit
de tolérance et de compromis au dialogue
il faut placer l'intérêt des
peuples
au-dessus de son parti ou de ses envies
personnelles sans cela il n'y a pas de
démocratie
réelle la trè question que nous devons
relever ensemble la 5è question que
c'est la question de la foi l'Islam a
une grande tradition de tolérance
nous l'avons vu dans
l'histoire d'Andalousie ou de Cordou
pendant
l'Inquisition et en tant qu'enfant en
Indonésie j'ai vu que les chrétiens
pouvent célébrer leur culte librement
dans un pays majoritairement musulman
voilà l'esprit dont nous avons besoin
aujourd'hui les gens dans tous les pays
devrai être libr de pouvoir choisir le
leur foi et la
vivreond sur leur intime conviction la
conviction de leur âme et de leur esprit
cette tolérance est essentielle pour que
les religions vivent mais elle a été
mise en
péril de bien des
façons parmi certains musulmans il y a
une tendance à mesurer la foi que l'on a
par le degré de rejet de la foi
d'autrui et pourtant le
rejet la diversité doit faire tout
l'objet de nos efforts
au Liban ou ici même en
Égypte et si nous devons
être honnête il faut également
travailler au sein même de
l'Islam éviter les divergences entre
sunit et ch et leur lutte violente en
particulier en Irak la liberté de culte
est essentielle pour la capacité des
peuples à vivre ensemble nous devons
toujours voir la manière de les protéger
ces libertés de culte par exemple aux
États-Unis
des règles sur la charité ont fait qu'il
était plus difficile pour les musulmans
de répondre à leurs obligations
religieuses c'est pour ça que je suis
engagé à travailler avec les musulmans
d'Amérique pour nous assurer qu'ils
puissent respecter les précepts de leur
religion de la même manière il est
important pour les pays occidentaux
d'éviter de discriminer
euh les musulmans dans la pratique de
leur religion par exemple en leur
imposant des tenues vestimentaires ou en
interdisant
d'autres en fait la foi devrait nous
rassembler et c'est pour cela que nous
développons des
projets aux États-Unis qui rassemble
musulmans juifs et
chrétiens c'est ce que nous avons dit
avec ro Abd récemment
ou en
Turquie des liens entre les peuples m
l'action par exemple lutter contre la
malaria en Afrique ou apporter notre
aide après une catastrophe
naturelle 6è
point le 6è point que je voulais
soulever aujourd'hui est le droit des
femmes
je
sais je sais et on peut le dire
puisque aujourd'hui qu'il a vrai débat
sur la questionors je rejette la vision
des occidentauelon laquelle une femme
qui choisit de se couvrir les cheveux
est moins
égale mais par contre je
crois à la même
éducation question
d'égalité
il ne fait aucune ce n'est pas une
coïncidence si les pays où les femmes
sont bien
éduquées ont plus de chance de connaître
la prospérité alors je serai clair la
question de l'égalité des genres ne sont
pas uniquement une question pour
l'Islam en Turquie au Pakistan au
bangladesch en
Indonésie nous avons vu des pays à
majorité musulmane qui ont choisi une
femme pour
leader et pourant la lutte pour
l'égalité des genres continue d'être
mené dans bien des aspects de la vie
américaine et dans bien des aspects des
beaucoup de pays du monde entier et je
suis convaincu que nos filles peuvent
participer à aider la société tout
autant que nos
fils notre prospérité
conjointe avancera si nous permettons à
l'ensemble de l'humanité hommes et femme
de donner leur plein
potentiel je ne crois pas que les femmes
doivent faire les mêmes choix que les
hommes pour être le leur égal je
respecte les femmes qui ont décidé de
vivre leur vie de manière traditionnelle
mais ce doit être leur choix et c'est
pour cela que les États-Unis seront les
partenaires de tout pays la majorité
musulmane qui développeront des
programmes et aideront les filles et les
femmes
à se dévelo à apprendre pour pouvoir
ainsi faire en sorte que chacun a accès
à ses propres
rêves et pour finir je souhaitais
revenir sur les opportunités de
développement économique je sais que
pour beaucoup la mondialisation présente
des aspects
contradictoires Internet et la
télévision peuvent apporter le savoir et
l'information mais peuvent
également êre re la source de violence
ou d'abus sexuel il y a donc beaucoup
d'opportunités beaucoup de possibilités
mais aussi beaucoup de risques dans
toutes les nations y compris aux
États-Unis ce changement que auquel nous
assistons peut susciter la crainte la
peur que en raison de la modernité nous
perdions un certain contrôle sur nos
choix économiques sur nos politiques et
encore plus important nos identités
C crainte est
partagé la peur de perdre nos traditions
nos familles et nos fois mais je sais
également que le progrès humain ne peut
être
ignoré il ne serait y avoir de
contradiction entre développement et
tradition des pays comme le Japon ou la
Corée du Sud ont bâti leurs économies et
qui ont grandi de manière très forte
tout en maintenant leur culture
traditionnel il en va de même dans
beaucoup de pays la majorité musulmane
de kaladungpour à
Dubaï anciennement et de nos jours les
communautés musulmanes ont été à
l'avant-garde de l'éducation de
l'innovation et c'est un élément
important parce qu'aucune stratégie de
développement ne saurait s'appuyer
uniquement sur ce qui vient de la
terre aucune économie ne peut être dur
les jeunes sont au chômage si nous
appuons uniquement par exemple sur le
pétrole nous devons tous reconnaître que
l'éducation
l'innovation seront les Monnes d'échange
du 21e siècle les devises du 21e siècle
et dans de trop nombreuses communautés
musulmanes ces domaines font l'objet de
sous-investissement de même que dans mon
pays nous allons insister sur C pointl
et même si de par le passé les
États-Unis étaient intéressés dans cette
région du monde par le pétrole et le gaz
nous nous engageons sur l'éducation par
exemple nous allons développer des
programmes de bourse et d'échang les
mêmes bourses échanges qui ont permis à
mon père de venir en
Amérique dans le même temps nous
encouragerons les élèves américains à
étudier dans les communautés
musulmanes et
nous inciterons les étudiants musulmans
à venir bénéficier de Bours pour
apprendre aux États-Unis et les enfants
du monde entier de la même manière pour
créer ainsi un vrai réseau mondial de de
cette manière un jeune au Kas pourra
communauté communiquer immédiatement
avec un jeune haer sur le développement
économique nous allons bâtir
un un ensemble de volontaires pour
travailler avec les pays musulmans et
nous allons avoir un sommet sur
l'entrepreneuriat cette année pour
identifier les liens que nous pourrons
créer entre les fondations les
responsables économiques et les
entrepreneurs aux États-Unis et dans les
communautés musulmanes du monde entier
sur les sciences et la technologie nous
allons lancer un nouveau son fond pour
soutenir le développement technologique
dans les pays majorité musulmane et
transférer ces idéesl sur les marchés
pour pouvoir créer davantage
d'emplois il y a une excellence
scientifique partout dans le monde et
nous allons insister sur ce point pour
collaborer à des programmes qui
développent de nouvelles sources
d'énergie par exemple créer des emplois
vert de l'eau propre des fichiers
numériques faire pousser de nouvelles
culture travaillons par exemple avec le
monde musulman pour éradiquer la la
polio nous allons accroître les
partenariats avec les communautés
musulmanes pour promouvoir les soins aux
maires et enfants tout ceci doit se
faire en partenariat les Américains sont
disposés à se rapprocher des citoyens et
des gouvernements des organisations des
communautés des
leaders religieux et les entreprises
musulmanes du monde entier pour aider
les gens à avoir une vie
meilleure et les points que j'ai soulevé
aujourd'hui ne seront
pas faciles à appréhender mais nous
avons la responsabilité de nous
rassembler au nom du monde que nous
envisageons un monde où l'extrémisme ne
menace plus nos peuples et un monde où
les troupes américaines sont rentré à la
maison un monde où les Israéliens et les
Palestiniens ont leur propre état chacun
en toute sécurité où l'énergie nucléaire
est utilisé à des fins Pacifi un monde
où les gouvernements servent leurs
citoyens et les droits de tous les
enfants de Dieu sont respect
voil nos intérêts commun voilà le monde
que nous envisageons mais nous ne
pourrons l'atteindre
qu'ensemble je sais que
beaucoup musulmans et non
musulmans se pose la question de savoir
si nous pouvons bâtir ce nouveau départ
ensemble certains ont soif de raviver la
flamme de la division de s'écarter de la
voix du
progrèss suèent que ça va pas pas la
peine que notre destin est le désaccord
et que les civilisations sont voué à la
confrontation beaucoup sont tout
simplement scepties quant à la
possibilité d'apporter un vrai
changement il y a tellement de peur
tellement de méfiance qui s'est bâti
avec les avec le temps mais si nous
choisissons d'être lié par le passé nous
n'avancerons
jamais et je veux dire cel au plus jeun
de toute confession dans tous les pays
vous plus que quiconque avez la capacité
à réinventer le monde à refaçonner ce
monde nous
tous partageons ce
monde sur une période très courte
finalement et la question est savoir si
nous allons utiliser ce temps pour nous
diviserou nous all profit pour nous
rassembler développer un effort conjoint
pour trouver un terrain commun pour nous
concentrer sur l'avenir que nous
souhaitons léguer à nos enfants et pour
respecter la dignité de l'ensemble des
êtres
humains c'est facile plus facile de
lancer de commencer des guerres Plô que
d'y mettre fin c'est plus facile de
donner la faute aux autres que de se
remettre en question soi-même c'est plus
facile de voir la différence chez
quelqu'un
que de voir les choses que nous
partageons mais nous devons choisir le
bon chemin et pas simplement le chemin
le plus
facile il y a une règle au cœur de toute
les religions c'est
celle de faire à autrui ce que nous
aimerions qu'il nous fasse de pas faire
ce pas
qu'
c'est cette vérité transcende va au-delà
des nations et des peuples ce n'est
pas une question de clivage il n'y a pas
noir blanc ou jaune il n'y a pas
musulman chrétiens ou juifs non il faut
croire en la civilisation et cette
croyance apparaît encore chez beaucoup
beaucoup de monde dans le monde et c'est
la foi en l'autre et c'est cela qui m'a
amené ici aujourd'hui nous avons le
pouvoir de fabriquer le monde que nous
voulons mais à la seule condition
d'avoir le courage de prendre un nouveau
départ en gardant en tête ce qui a été
fait et ce qui a été écrit le Coran nous
dit que toute l'humanité a été créée
hommes et
femmes qui sont organisés en nation et
en tribu pour que l'on se connaisse les
uns les autres
le talm nous
dit que l'ensemble de la T vise à la
promotion de la
paix la Bible nous
dit bé soit les faiseurs de
paix car ils seront appelés fils de
Dieu
les peuple du monde entier peuvent vivre
ensemble dans la paix nous savons que
c'est là la vision de Dieu et maintenant
nous nous devons travailler à cela ici
sur Terre merci à tous et que la paix de
Dieu soit avec vous merci à
tous